[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
yes sir
what's going on around Sunday Sunday the
lowest day we are back we are back see
how these levels are sounding let's see
what's going on out here
Gerald Mack the OG good to see you good
to see you all hella IOP salute I see I
see you earlier I saw the video up he
says the Lord's day keep it respectful
yes indeed yes indeed we are here I'm
feeling good
what's going on lydian Master what's up
what's up talk to me Zach carium what's
going on crazy Greek dude
who's going on good to see y'all up in
there oh destroy the Lords yes yes yes
we are here we are here it's gonna be a
good one shout out all the Broncos okay
okay I see you
live Supremacy what's going on talk to
me talk to me no doubt sound turn up
Cami
karus that's how you pronounce it let's
go let's go let's get to see y'all got a
good one line that way for the rest of
lawyers to get up in here
before spoke to King earlier he had a
good uh combat talk stream last night I
was up in the airplane and it's a silver
and um Jake Paul excuse me King was
hilarious and um yeah so I will be in
the building and we got a special guests
Charlie plays live looking forward to
picking his names for talented dude you
know what I mean and we gonna have a fun
show we got a lot of stuff to get into
I'm excited but um yes I'm gonna get
what's up silver lab guy what's going on
I'm looking forward to a fun one y'all
looking forward to a four one got a lot
of stuff going on but um yeah I'm gonna
go get some people see what's up with
addicts see where everybody at
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be using these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rains you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just for
the original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all too
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got you
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that yoga fire plane they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless and people don't aim check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing it
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when he was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social
knowing my city but I'm still by Coastal
I got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
am look y'all messed up and turned me to
an animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use the video game
just be original you also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
using these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got you
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my titty but I'm still
bi-coastal I got you that's
[Music]
who
and we are alive I Am Lord podcast Lord
Cognito here talking about the latest
with Advanced GG there's a lot of things
going on with the new product live let's
get right to it
so we got that Focus line y'all this is
that standard that's what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing this Focus or debt number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta Adeline so you don't get the
Jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know Cog
love is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to advancedg.com use code iron Lord on
the checkout this is something I use all
the time got to support Advanced EG
great products if you want to get your
workout on even if you don't work out
you're just gaming you need that focus
and again the hydration in line for
those who don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lower
Cognito here iron Lord podcast peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
my check my check and I believe we are
live somebody call for something just
want to see a level there you go yeah
always feel good
all right so I was gonna leave I gotta
go
all right here you hear you and we are
live welcome to the iron Lords podcast
LLC and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number
278. that's another glorious Sunday and
we are back at the round table on the
Lord's date very excited about our
special guest and we've got Game Pass
profitability and price hikes
God of War Ragnarok settings
and Persona 5 Xbox success to discuss so
we gonna get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord who's
unique and multi-talented skill set is
equally matched by his immense passion
for gaming whether it be his Mastery of
software entertaining us with classic
game streams or creating melodic albums
for us to rock out to
introducing the software engineer
musical composer panelists of the best
gaming podcast and host of the Johnny
plays live twitch and YouTube channels
man I wasn't ready for that we ain't
finished
who streams much better with friends yet
is easily overshadowed by basil the cat
these are the cats that started the show
the producer for sure live from the UK
we not finished with you by the way of
Brazil and making his debut into the
realm of the Lord my man Lord Johnny
plays live how we doing sir man thank
you for the super warm welcome it's an
honor to be in the show I've followed
you guys for a long time and uh
huge honor yeah and uh yeah just excited
man to talk talk about some [ __ ]
games
no no curse but we appreciate it we
appreciate your exuberance
oh thank you in fact there's an act of
like meeting you halfway unmatching my
man Cognito with the glasses
okay okay I see what we thought no doubt
you're saying so what have you been
playing sir games have you been playing
dude this week I've been on a on a bench
playing grounded our friends have you
guys gotten around to trying that oh yes
and someone has a very good review of
all his channel of the game oh yeah
someone added really good review that I
checked out you broke that thing down
really yeah we we actually streamed it
and had one of our most hilarious
moments addict remember yeah there's a
lot of hilarious moments on that but I'm
getting hunted by a spider yes yes yes
yeah they were mad at me for making a
run into a deep end what is it a air
cave and then we came out and it was
fighting at the top it was hilarious but
yeah so you've been rocking the rocket
grounded
yeah man yeah it's been surprisingly
good it's just solid you know because
survival games you guys know how it is
man oftentimes they're just flawed and
technical issues all over the shop and
this one the co-op works really well the
the the save has a really cool system
you notice that it's like Cloud saved
and then people sink it all over the
place just works you know like like that
guy said yeah it just works
and yeah it's been great man
um nice do you think that is because the
game was in beta for so long that they
got a time to curate the game and get
the game and listen to all the back uh
backlash early on to fix whatever
problems it was before they initially
released you know what I think so
because this feature specifically was
actually added recently and it was a
direct result of feedback and I know
that many others were too I gotta tell
you I don't know about you guys I'd be
curious to hear what you think about
Early Access in general yeah I have a
like a love-hate relationship with it
because games that are just endlessly in
Early Access yeah oh it triggers me
because I'm playing satisfactory as well
and it's like after years it's still
unfinished and you go you get to the end
game and like blueprints are unfinished
and stuff like that it just triggers you
know what I don't like um about
um Early Access Johnny the fact that
they're not paying me for beta yeah I
know beta boy talk I think I get a
little more annoyed that it's not
utilized more I feel like CT should have
been in Early Access uh there's certain
games that deserve to be in it but
aren't in it and they're certain games
that really capitalize off being in it
like I I actually feel like
low-key that should be people that you
know uh play uh test that bill okay yeah
yeah considered a full game okay you can
go straight to the front of the line if
it's not like duh it's got to go to game
access they're building six gotta go
there and then once they say you pass
that that that you know test then they
would reroute you back to building one
yeah that was but a lot of grounded and
all that good good to hear good to hear
you rocking that yeah we gotta get back
on that that was a lot of fun and you
already know we got the four horses for
the game and those original Lords of the
realm here at the round table my co-host
with the co-motes my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man Lord addict
of the attic show how we doing sir I'm
doing pretty good I was actually you
know
working on the review for uh Mario
Sparks I hope and it just wasn't going
to be done before the podcast you know I
beat it yeah uh yesterday after uh I
beat it the day before yesterday set
that ball sounded crazy right yeah the
boss is actually I I honestly say that
that ball it's like one of those things
like turn-based games don't normally
like make you use everybody and spoiler
alert like the boss and Spark of hopes
they're like we don't care you using
everybody
and most games don't make you do that I
know octopi traveler did and that
actually Sparks the hopes that it does
it better because occupied Travelers you
don't use other characters that's just
how it is like you you're not they're
they're not getting Auto leveled up with
your Mains your main party but in in
this new Mario game they do auto level
everyone when you level okay half the
team the other half gets good because
then it influences you to still use the
other characters
try them out like an octopi tribe looks
like nah only people out in these
streets
what's up you better take these other
people off the bench and level them up
so it was a lot easier to go into that
final battle knowing that you know okay
I got to learn their abilities because I
didn't use some I didn't use uh Luigi
rabbit any the entire game like not one
time and I didn't even know what his
ability did no love for Luigi man come
on no I know I use the Ouija just not
the rabbit Luigi
because yeah regular Luigi is like a
sniping yeah the whole game yeah
yeah so it's just like you know it it
was a fun little game I do have issues
with them continuing to like how does
Nintendo not investing into voice acting
but indie games do I just don't don't
get it like like I just I find it I'm
playing this game it actually has an
okay narrative it's an okay narrative
it's not like great but it's actually
enough to keep you in there but then
when I hear like the even Mario and them
don't have yeah yeah
I just like like come on man
where it's just like
it's like world clearly is what they I
don't even know what the stories were on
the individual would have liked Chris
Pratt to uh actually yeah Chris Pratt
would have been a a nice a nice thing
but you know guess what I I literally
she's like come on man you know what
it's it's us we the problem we keep
giving Nintendo money so why do they go
into it they've been empowered based on
their their sales and how successful
that's exactly it man and they've gotten
away well Japanese Market in general has
gotten away with very little voice
acting in general for ever right you can
look at any jrpg even the ones that have
great voice acting yeah there is 80 of
the game where you're doing side quests
and you're reading that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah absolutely no doubt and of
course we have our most technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the Sasha Davis the Lord of clarity
and Lord patreon of the iron bank my man
Lord Sovereign how we doing sir coming
in hot
that's super hot
a little bit under the table you know
last night was date night and you know
okay date night is usually not super
eventful we just have dinner talk about
you know the week's events just be able
to unwind but we went to a new
restaurant last night and we didn't know
they had like entertainment oh so we got
treated to a nice like uh Halloween
themed uh Flamenco show
oh yeah it was it was nice so it was
like oh wow and then then uh they had
this drink there that it was like um
yeah it was so it was it was rum
Knitters lime and Tamarind I don't know
if you guys like Tamarind I love
Tamarind I think I had it once in um
so oh my goodness so they brought me the
first one it was like this is juice this
is all exactly went down easy he was
like oh this is nice and then three
three in I'm like oh man
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the only thing I got to play
oh you got them nights
what's going on in these streets Gotham
Knights don't even try it on your steam
don't do that oh no
[Music]
when you start it goes into you you have
you have Corridor stuff and you're
indoors kind of you don't really see
what's going on
it fools you like after the intro
cutscene and stuff like that you get in
there and you're like okay I can deal
with this you know adjusting
what's going on today
you loaded that up on the stream deck
anyways
[Music]
if you would let me finish my story
you never let me finish my story like I
said don't do that
on the PC right load it up got a PC but
I could actually see the game for what
it is
so tell me how it looks on PC then is it
running well do you have stutters like
we saw in some videos you definitely
have some stutters it looks I mean in
terms of like
uh weather effects and stuff like that
when you have that all going it looks
pretty good right but the thing about it
is that the open world is a lot more
limited that they would lead you to
believe like it is you know it's there
isn't a whole lot going on in the street
even when you have like a high amount of
like crowd density and stuff like that
the way they separate things out where
you go out on patrols and you're looking
for crimes and stuff like that you can't
just say hey I just want to go through
the story missions no you have to go do
these crimes in order to unlock certain
things and
so the thing about it and playing it I'm
like
it really does look like this game was
supposed to be a service game straight
up right yeah reception Maddie said that
to me yeah no and it makes 100 sense
they saw the reception to Avengers and
pivoted right and the thing about it is
that when they pivoted I think they made
the Fatal mistake of not pivoting and
saying let's trash it and start over
gotcha right because they were they've
already been this game took eight years
to come out yeah and I mean obviously at
some point sunken cost the game has to
come out but this is really really
disappointing as a game because what
they did was was take that corpse of
that game that they had and try to build
around it some something that still has
you know kind of the numbers going up
and the upgrades and stuff like that but
it isn't
it just it's not a satisfactory one of
those because the rest of it that was
supposed to charge you for and all this
other stuff or whatever the guts of that
is still there and impeding on on the
rest of the game design and so rather
than go back to the drawing board say
hey we have to start over and let's just
make a a classic sort of Batman action
game yeah
they went this route and honestly man
they
I don't know that they're longing for
this world bro yeah you took a long time
looking spooky because you took so long
to make this game right rather than say
hey let's just rockstead he's making
something different they make us
indifferent let's take the reins of what
Batman was people want a Batman type
game so give them that with the bat
family I like I like the idea of the
Batman I like the idea of the the
quarter mile stuff I like the idea of
Batman actually being dead and dead yeah
he did yeah man he told me he was like
no no he don't know don't blow it up
you know what it is
hard first first five minutes of the
game uh oh it tells you in the first
five minutes
they don't tell they show you
okay okay now um
well yeah it just feels like they could
have they could have made that type of
Batman game when everybody loves and it
could have made it their own because
they Rock Steady pivoted yeah and they
did this yesterday
with the Board Room the how much money
was sunk into the game oh yeah right
yeah yeah it just is if you think it's a
patch worthy like later like they're
they're gonna you know patch it up
because I hear everybody likes certain
parts of it it's just the abysmal frame
rate uh and a lot of this uh Junction
and some spots I mean it definitely is
it'll be a more polished game at some
point that is for sure right we can
always count on that especially a WB
game they have to right right it sunk so
much money into this I don't know how
their sales were but they have to yeah
so I expect it to be a good performing
game at some point
um I just don't know yeah exactly but
cyberpunk at the core is is a very good
game I don't know that this is foreign
the overall story is what I'm interested
in I want to see how they handle
quarterballs without Batman in it
um because that's a very personal Batman
story so I just want to see how they
handle it and because again I I don't
know man like Arkham Origins was much
better than this really what about the
combat dude because the combat looked
fun to me I was like oh the combat seems
different fun but it's not check this
out right so the combat yeah
okay check this out no more there's no
more counter button when you counter
into a flow right now is an evade button
the evade button essentially lets you
get out of the way of Combos and then
come right back in with your combos but
it's not something that you're literally
countering a shot and then jumping back
in with your own it that type of precise
timing isn't necessary anymore so it
feels like a different game right and on
top of that you're unlocking different
stuff you're locking different moves and
access another thing about it is
these guys the traversal around the
world should be one of the main pillars
of this game and why it's dope right if
you look at Batman and how he traverses
that world obviously none of them fly in
that regard maybe Batgirl could but
getting around on the motorcycles
getting around on like you don't have
that sense of motion that you had in the
Batman games yeah they kind of tease it
with a a breath of the wild type of uh
what you call glider type thing but even
then that isn't it that it's just not
and and I'm just like
how do you not take these Heroes who
whose core sort of ability sets are all
about acrobatics and they're not you
know traversing through traversing the
world like in a way that's super
satisfying it everything about that
stuff it's not horrible because I'm not
saying it's poorly done but for what you
expect these characters to be able to do
I think is poorly implemented and I
don't think it was the right decision to
make so it's just a lot of it they made
it they made changes for the sake of
making changes instead of hey how can we
Elevate this formula that was there
before and I don't know man there you
have it that's awesome
because you said you weren't sure if
it's doing well or not check this out
right as you said check this out right
now
as of the 2nd of October UK this is only
UK sales charts which is what I was
looking at um number one game FIFA 23
unexpected number two game Gotham
Knights yeah
I'm curious to see those uh refund cells
on stage
actually it's mostly positive on Steam
after the initial blowback yeah because
initially it was getting review bombed
believe it or not because of the frame
rate on consoles which is to me
ridiculous you're playing the game on PC
you should be reviewing it on that
platform and not review bombing it for
you know yeah which admittedly it's it's
a shitty thing right the language like
no performance mode I I understand the
frustration no doubt no doubt so that's
pretty much yourself that's pretty much
it yeah and get excited for Ragnarok
when it got I actually I booted up I
booted up God of War man I booted it up
with New Game Plus in it yeah yeah yeah
we're gonna get into that yeah
and I want to see the angle on this one
yeah
and of course we have returning the
incredible Hulk of this aka the access
gamer
the prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues there bears nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King you were missed last
week how you doing oh man I missed the
show last week I was uh you ever need
something like it's therapeutic and if
you don't get that thing like you're
addicted I'm addicted to the show right
you don't get it for that week and it
seems like your whole week is like going
down a downward Hill
I could give my topics and I'm like be
good you can say all right bro you're
allowed to miss it you're chomping at
the [ __ ]
because he's listening to us talking
about he's like wait a minute no I can
say this I can say that yo that's just
me in the car and I just felt like
Anderson Silva you know like shout out
to him and Jake last name first of all
shout out to everybody that came out to
my comment I had a hundred live yeah the
the like to live ratio was immense uh
unlike right now where I see 400 people
and I only see a 108. you heard kick hit
that like button hit those like she
walked out swipe your feet hit the like
the light though come on now thank you
notified people send it out I do
appreciate that I mean you did it last
night so what is it a me thing or
anything hey right fantastic I
appreciate you but um everybody was
there we was rocking out we was talking
about it and it was good boxing going on
on traditional boxing right we had
lomachenko versus Ortiz and that was a
good fight within itself then you had
MMA going on over there and that was a
good uh MMA match within itself but Jake
has this polarizing Mayweather effect
either you hate him absolutely
or you are with this guy ride or die
like you screaming down the street your
car's on fire and you're having such a
great time with this dude because you
already know he's there for all of us I
call him
he's the ultimate gotcha hat dude
and when he stole Floyd maywe with his
hat that was just the tip of the iceberg
and last night it seemed like Anderson
was on his way to do it so oh yeah to
getting this kid and lo and behold this
kid bit down and put your hero on his
cheeks
and in that moment I felt everybody
everybody that was watching that was
hoping that he was gonna get it I felt
all of our hearts hit the floor at the
same time and that's when we realized
like Anderson Silva realized that the
ref had bow-legged knees
from that perspective without it did I
get here and his face he was it was so
dejected it was so not like this please
not now and everybody want to hit me and
tell me oh it's fixed it was a fixed
Fight King it was not a fixed fight
um I I have I can debate to Deontay
Wilder fight but I cannot debate this I
thought Anderson tried his hardest I
thought he was a little bit out of his
age Zone I thought um Jake was very
three very strategic with his jab very
fundamental in a lot of places and he
was doing things that normal veterans do
so that means this boy is taking a
serious he's training and he's bringing
and he packed the house something
incredible to see I have nothing but
Kudos with somebody that's going to Will
and try and get to their spot so again
Cog was watching and he was chiming in
in the chat if anybody had a chance to
watch
um I have people that didn't know about
sports and said uh thanks for the
commentary to to have them understand
certain things so it was a great time
this week shout out to you brother shout
out to you brother because to maintain a
conversation with yourself yeah
he'd be entertaining himself
I've known Game Pass to drop two or
three games here and there
this holiday theme this scary thing
where where humble games is down where
the 505 is in with a um uh fractional uh
games is down with it the uh
uh Amnesia collection I've never played
it
this is some of the scariest stuff that
you can put there for a kid to pick up
no you don't don't my son picked it up
and came down oh no like that's not for
me like like no no yo and those games
are old they cut look kind of old but
still scary as hell what's and you
should you should the rebirth Amnesia
rebirth is like the sequel to those they
have it there on Game Pass as well yeah
yeah about it you should play the Five
Night at Freddy's like I don't think
those are scarier but like they they
it's like the creep up effect like
you're just sitting there with the
anticipation and you're expecting it to
happen every five minutes but it does it
but when it does happen it just catches
you off guard yeah yeah my daughter
plays that the jump scares she she loves
that stuff so you had some Soma
which looks pretty good downloaded that
but this is one game that I downloaded
that didn't know anything about right
and it's a signalus I I believe it's
called yeah
um
it's
3D it feels it feels real 32-bit okay
Phil's real 32 it transported me back to
Dreamcast it felt like blue blue Stinger
right really 32-bit type of game but
it's scary you're on a spaceship and and
the story looks really good so I'm
trying to delve deep into that game but
Game Pass for everybody that says you
know and financially I'm not running out
there buying a billion games can't do it
yeah uh but this allows me to get my
fright on like we sit down me and my son
sat there he was like you can play it I
can watch and he sat there he was eating
a Hot Pocket while I'm playing this game
and he's like Daddy this is absolutely
scary because I do a traditional turn
off oh you gotta turn the lights get the
atmosphere I see what you're doing get
into it
with the bright lights
you know it's funny yeah you know what's
hilarious we will have a legit eye
doctor come on here tell you not to do
that but you guys want me yeah
all you need is
[Laughter]
well that's the only thing that I've
been doing that in fortnite um when I
got a chance this has just been uh the
week from hell but uh hopefully this
week is a whole lot better and I get a
chance to get into these games but again
Game Pass is alive and healthy no doubt
salute salute The Game Pass and all that
and of course we got the game release
himself to Shinobi Lord Cognito spread
that real into the rubber to IOP and
I'll tell you what you whatever what you
need to hear shout out to Friday dude
shout out to Mr Betty please got a
chance to rock out with him and then of
course uh secret symbols the crossover
episode a lot of fun in the LSM family
to that
um last word when he brought to sagai
Travis and we had
um uh attic we had DJ auros
DJ arroz fold up the destiny bestie a
lot of fun man it was absolutely
hilarious talking about Festival of the
bugs I mean the Lost excuse me
bro Bungie getting dragged right now
these bugs quests not working things not
dropping and apparently I haven't played
in a while so when I played it was they
were like you didn't experience blah
blah it was I was like no they were like
they experienced all these things but
they couldn't like progress quests yeah
it's really what's happening to the
Quality
oh here you go
it is the PlayStation effect they're uh
they're punishing people that play day
one
yeah but if you wait you know you you
good you're good messy anyway we talk
about that as far as a little proves but
um yeah as far as being with the gaming
man find the lease VR for your weekend
yeah turns your boy you know what I'm
saying wait I think my my man asked for
it he said we need to show it yes please
please
we finally got the commercial device
we got the commercial level device
where's the price tag on it this is
commercial use this is yes
they got it the Best Buy right next to
the TCL right yeah
that will never be found in the teeth
they got it they got it in Target right
beside the poor showers for life
insurance
next to the Porsches yeah it was a
Lamborghini so I got my joy yesterday I
read I got that notification like oh is
that the post something right over there
to go get that and then um
I know cause I got a rule when it's like
a a pack like you no shipping directly
to be where you leave it in front my
house no no no you gonna go drop that
off at the drop-off center where the
signature is required we are not doing
that so anyway yeah yeah I go from you
know it's funny the stuff some of the
stuff that solver sent for Signature
this is how bad UPS FedEx they all it's
like they all are managed by Calvin
because like who sit there and they'll
do like a signature thing and they still
won't ask for a signature they'll just
still put it down yeah man so I wake up
that Drake look super premium product
the feel is nice love to charge your
charger dock is really cool got a chance
to mess around with a little bit of
mixed reality a little in the face how's
the face of the facial is is more
impressive because it's like you put it
on and then they have you go through a
lot of digs with your eye testing as far
as like where you're moving stuff like
that and then I think an um Horizon is
where you notice it because to be honest
there's not a lot of software that
utilizes detectors Horizon forbidden
West no we're right
the world sir oh my man up here your dad
don't say how many pillows did y'all buy
for this yo you stupid yeah I gotta buy
the pillows you'll see okay you want to
go ahead and do that go for it oh just
finish your story so
um yeah so we rock it I'm doing that so
you can see it I think I put a clip up
there's a person on my on my Twitter
yeah the technical dude yeah and then
what it is is like the fact that it
could catch a mouth movement and your
eye position your expression if you're
making a face you know what I'm saying
and it's really impressive in that
regard you know but to be honest even
though that's super impressive
AR impressed me y'all like play I had DB
and we're gonna talk I had demio in the
crib oh shout out to the homie I see CJ
up in there CJ shout out to Sinister
shout out to um volcano we had a mad fun
dbo session we did um we'll just get the
realm of the Rat King dungeon we did all
three levels finished that bad boy I had
a fun time you know what I'm saying but
manipulate I can't play it regular VR no
more you got to do it like you could
your king you could squeeze it down to
so like really small if you want you
could put it like on Attack on your
table did that one time I squeezed it
mad big I had to I put a picture up I
had like it covered my entire room and I
elevated it put it on an angle and all
that it's crazy like happy and then when
you throw the dice and you see it
manipulate off the wall because you have
to set up the walls of your house first
yeah of your playing area like you know
how you do the boundary if you are in
the floor yes for AR you got to do the
boundary like you got to make walls so
they know okay this is the place and
then you got the couch and all that
whatever whatever so um yeah that's
where that price shout out to my being
CJ he said 18 pillows for one Quest Pro
not bad y'all stupid yo one one question
I have
um
how's the resolution oh that yeah
get to get to get to the differences
yeah between the two I know this one's
going a little bit long but yeah I mean
I really want to know more about this
part how's the resolution because this
is a direct competition to somebody else
who's trying to come out does it look
like Xbox One series X or PS5
that's definitely nice first of all you
got to pick the pancake lenses and
immediately when you blew it off you'll
see the sharpness with the resolution
then you know when you notice it's the
text it's it's super vibrant and the
color palette is just like even the when
you double tap you do the past rule the
color the color is really vibrant and
stuff like that the thing about the
device where I really like super
lightweight here's my main thing addict
you gonna appreciate this VR people who
buy glasses gang
it's not good for VR normally but the
pro broke like it sits oh like out front
so there's a space so you can wear
glasses you don't have that weight on
your nose because the way they did it is
I don't know if you ever had the uh the
battery pack which is like an elite trap
it's basically they took the pro and the
strap attachment made it a device which
is pretty much this this this part here
yeah it's pretty much like what the um
you have to buy this as a separate
attachment and it had the battery the
back then you squeeze this joint in you
can squeeze this and then you could like
squeeze it to your head like so now it's
just integrated into the core machine
yeah
yeah so it's no longer like a premium
attachment and the thing is lightweight
so I'm very impressed like I'm not going
for like glasses where is this is only
the only thing I got this
battery life yeah
um
yeah I thought so hopefully but the cool
thing is you can charge and play and um
when you charge it has a fast charge
mechanic so it doesn't really take long
if you plug it and play at the same time
to go back up to 100 and then be back in
for like two or three hours if you can
walk around with better questions your
battery packs and just uh do I mean if
you do the old school but the thing is I
don't know if the battery Pack's gonna
have no voltage for this for this device
that's what makes her yeah so the better
question is what has a better battery
that or the PS5 controller
obviously frames resolution shout out to
my boy what's the name of this I think
they called jump ship Studio I retweeted
I shot at the mount last night hold on I
gotta give credit to this studio they
were all vertical robot shout out to
Vertical robot they got a game called
red matter too
boy you in space you got um this little
devices you can manipulate stuff
I'm gonna tell you right now that's when
you see the phobiated joint that's what
you see because the foliated rendering
whatever you looking at
it focuses the graphics on that and it's
intense detail like I picked up a
document that had fingerprints on it all
type but like I'm seeing it so clear I'm
like yo the figure like real life
pictures of people I'm like this is
crazy yo red matter too I've seen red
matter 2 on regular Quest did this ain't
it the resolution the local dimming the
higher graphical for daily I was like
okay this is I see what's going on now
yeah that is next level and then the eye
tracking is crazy it gives you a sense
of being in space you got your space
suit you're jumping around you're seeing
the background the moon and all that you
jump in a little satellite fly off to it
red matter too is it I'm telling y'all
right now go check that if you if if you
happen to have the commercial device I
would say go get that yeah that that's a
that is a showcase piece that's actually
using some of the newer Tech but yeah
I've been rocking out that and then um
attic let's get into uh and I'll be
talking a lot but we got to get into
something we're thinking about going on
since everybody's worried about how I
got the pro
the just do the
um
the stuff for the website and stuff and
then we'll do it after that oh I gave it
to you I thought you was doing it
no no I'm talking about uh scribe of the
month and stuff oh okay okay so let's
actually solve let's can we get the
super chats and all that first yeah
hold on a second roll back Nano remember
for 29 months Lord Bronx thank you so
happy to see Lord Johnny here yes sir
and we got to put the crust in the chat
remember for two years Gerald Mack Lord
Silva
then we have B Lou remember for 15
months Lord bronze it's Lord's Day shout
out to the goat Anderson Sue Anderson
Spider Silva got in there 47 and fought
a good fight y'all keep killing it no
doubt
no doubt then we got 4gq TV five dollars
clowns no doubt clowns all hail the king
no doubt King is back then we got Master
clown X3 member for 22 months paying
homage to the Lords of gaming salute
thank you sir absolutely much love
we got harget Chinese remember for 17
months Lord gold the King has returned
to the king and those other guys
podcasts
kicking them dudes kicking them dudes
joke salute to the Lords welcome to the
realm Johnny plays lives no doubt so low
and we have rrd member for six months
two dollar Super Chat addict you already
wear glasses I don't know what he's
talking about there I guess it's the
scary stuff I don't know there was this
the playing with the lights off
stop complaining you're wearing glasses
you're fine
I shouldn't complain if I go even more
blind God
like because I have glasses you know
maybe I'm a little bit more more
cautious with my eyes
look like you already blind it's okay
we'll just ask the movie theater next
week to keep the lights on it's like
it's like it's like the equivalent of if
I'm convicted felon you already been to
jail one yeah
that's not the equivalent but that's
fine yeah
there we got heck that I'm not sure
the king is back oh hell the Lords and I
think Cog is being watched by the feds
of the CMA because he stopped pushing
powder is now pushing pillows oh by the
way you know what I'm saying go to
advancedg.com Links in the description
at the top let's pick at the tap 30 off
down man spooky squeezy the spooky
season go get the kids get that energy
get that powder do what you got to do
y'all okay go click that man
it was it was just a perfect transition
yeah
perfect setup it's delicious Advantage
is delicious you never gotta play
remember for two years I uh what you
would call log that's fine it's five
dollars for chat how do you buckaroos
we're all about jokes here but it's
definitely not a joke that God of War is
being so two weeks before lunch
disgraceful they said Cog is pushing
powder and pillows yodies
that was good that was good God of War
out there man and apparently it's not
just Mom and Pops to her selling it with
some retail stores and be like yeah
whatever
King are we or we wait until there's an
actual copy out in my area before you do
it listen
we gotta wait for the need
I think you want to try to get me next
week
you know what you trying to get me live
while we live
now listen foreign
[Applause]
this is what you get
you
you thought you had the gate
I call out of yesterday yo
if we get it early go get killed all
right first of all let's give proper
context
in the chat do not know what we talk
about y'all well no I I just I just want
to know who's snitching no you know what
you know what it is I'm a Visionary yeah
don't do that to me
I kept it tight bro I didn't tell him
nothing I tell that nothing what you was
thinking about I was like yo that's fire
if we do that live anyway let's give
proper cops it would have been dope
let's get proper context the the Lord's
right attic we're thinking about you
know doing a live show but in order to
get that going you know see we need a
little help from the realm right exactly
you know what I'm saying y'all know we
pushing um the pillows and all that so
they get these pillows going we got to
get these going link is up in the
description so let me let me show you
what I'll do is well we we we're looking
at this place uh to do it at and you
know we we
we don't do anything half we don't we
never do anything else the Lord
that's great so if if if if we do do
this and we sell six pillows that's
where we will be doing the podcast here
next Sunday nice round table Yeah so
that that that's where it will be nice
nice nice not now now that's not true is
that a real I can't tell no that's right
to pay for the festivities it's not we
need a little help you know what's funny
it's not your pillows the pillows that
that we're wanting to sell don't even
exceed like it it what we're paying for
this space is more than those pillows
yes way more we uh way more like almost
double so you know we get them six
pillows out uh you know I got a website
up you know go ahead and and tag me on
Twitter with the receipt too so I could
keep track of it in case all of them go
there you know we get them six pillars
next week you'll see it so I'm gonna put
the link back up in the description
y'all so again we can't try to move the
Volaris you know what I'm saying here's
the links in the description again if we
can get the six pillows that will
definitely help us towards doing IO IOP
live in the city you know what I'm
saying we come together do a special
episode episode
it's never happened if you think about
it yeah and keep keep in mind we we
did not save no expenses like yeah
they're gonna be a they're gonna be a
three camera angle if this goes through
you know I'm hyping this stuff up they
don't know what they're getting you want
this get that six pillars what what they
need to understand is this is our first
big promotion yeah you want manscape you
want Dr squash you want all this other
stuff yeah this this is our our baby and
we're trying to give you the best that
we can possibly give you so you want to
see this live show with all of us
sitting at a real round table together
with multiple angles and they thought
they was going to give me the bend the
knee live
[Laughter]
me up
we'll keep this movement going well see
you uh I agree for for for 10 from what
for the end of the month you guys bought
four so we just need an additional six
already yeah oh that's what's up that's
what's up
once the set the remaining six is done
then then we're doing that because I'm
gonna be there but if we don't get six
man I I you know I ain't go I ain't
waking up on Sunday it ain't happening
okay it's my vacation kinda dude I'm in
New York City you guys work for you want
that happen because attic ain't getting
up if I don't have to all right there's
plenty of other things I could do on a
Saturday afternoon when I'm not at home
to make your body day watch this no
doubt anyway he thought he was gonna get
me watch this I I confirm or deny
nothing uh
hold on a second job Mac I just want to
make sure I got these last but General
Mack thank you man salute yeah man thank
you brother yeah I'm gonna try that
contractors too as well he's talking I
got something for y'all no doubt and we
got we got it's got Mandingo Mexicans
remember for two years two dollars every
time I appreciate all you guys and the
hard work you put in daily thank you so
much I appreciate it really appreciate
it thank you
is going as as Nino Brown for Halloween
my brother Gerald Mack two dollar Super
Chat five dollars go two years five
dollars shout out to Laura Cognito
putting that Quest Pro on screen have
you tried contractors on that thing
that's gonna be next yeah and by the way
here's the um the controller controller
is glorious I've got to tell you that oh
that looks nice beautiful continue
and we got the man who got them horns
remember for 28 months Lord bronze love
listening to the king during the Paul
fight he missed last week looking for
Bud trying to make him fight Errol in
November hashtag Cog moving powder
pillows removing it baby go get that
yeah the man with them horns pulled up
on us last night
we caught up yep we're caught up all
right correct let's get this thing right
we got patient people that's been
sitting here give me a second yes sir
all right y'all know what time it is the
time of the month Lords gave me that net
we've been blessed to have this
tremendous tremendous writing talent and
all aspire to be great scribes of the
realm I want to shout out the entire
team as always the competition for this
is extremely Fair because we got some
damn good scribes y'all we got some
people we got some Talent you know what
I'm saying but and we are very blessed
so salute to them but now it's time to
celebrate a specific scribe who went
Above and Beyond in the month of October
exceptional reviews he had uh scored
hell has our Fury score and preview
review excuse me dial field Chronicle
absolutely killed that some Gran Turismo
7 updates we proudly present the latest
winner of the Lord dizzy log that scribe
of the month to Ben Scott AKA hit box
detective baby
absolute where you at where you at he
was here I don't see him anymore where'd
he go I'm here oh there we go he ain't
saying that there you go okay cool cool
yeah sorry I was waiting for the
Applause to settle down
absolutely
congratulations but tremendous about
speech
thank you so much no I really appreciate
it you know I I think you know I had
never written anywhere really outside of
like a Tumblr account somewhere and you
just started making videos and
um I was always you know you hear
stories of people like starting for
media outlets and not getting to write
what they really want and not be able to
voice their opinions or anything and
lognet has been really great and um you
know I think they're superlative in that
way
um
superlative I love it
that's right he's a scrum it's uh it's
really a pleasure and an honor and you
know yesterday I was really kind of
blindsided by uh yeah
when you know when Steve dropped that
article I was yeah you thought she was
in trouble yeah I was like when Steve
dropped the um the CMA article I was
like oh I don't know it's gonna be
spooky you know what I'm saying but now
you held it down man you held it down
well you know I really appreciate and I
appreciate the the freedom to create and
you know whenever I make a video and
attach it to my article and be able to
embed it that's really cool and you know
it's something I don't take for granted
I know that that's something that uh
most places don't let you do so uh I
really appreciate that
um yeah thank you all so much and by the
way this is the most fun I've ever seen
podcast hosts all having together it's
infectious and it's it's really cool I
like what y'all are doing yeah thank you
a tremendous asset to the team love your
enthusiasm love the passion for writing
and sky's the limit man I love you
multi-platforms boy play everything you
know he reminds me of right young
Spiderman
yeah
we got we got them early before you know
say he got big
before he get that the day before he got
the bike
oh people are asking is there a promo
code I don't know the promo code no for
if you click the email for the pillows
if they click the link the minute they
um click it and then they order it the
promo code will be applied automatically
so as long as I click that link that we
put in there you'll be good to go there
we go let's move some pillows yo I'm
gonna tell you man you'll see y'all
gonna see uh we get those uh 10 pillows
done we're gonna have I'm gonna make
sure my pillow is there for for this
live show no doubt but we got one more
announcement one more announce we wanted
to make a new announcement additional
Lords Lords gaming.net award to honor uh
brother Lord dizzy because one thing
about this he was a nurturer of talent
you know when we started loser
gaming.net and he always I want to make
this award for us to give the proper
credit to people behind the scenes who
don't get the shine they supposed to get
you know what I'm saying editing the
teaching just the lifeblood that keeps
the site going you know what I mean
because we give a lot of people
opportunities some people got legit jobs
for being that long net because of the
editorial team that we have so this is
the internet went above and beyond Call
of Duty last month you know what I'm
saying he's always been handed the keys
by another great editor shout out to
Lord Lord Josh and we haven't missed the
beat since he's been tremendous the the
positive energy the consistency and he's
a damn good scribe himself so we proudly
present the winner of the new Lord dizzy
lognet editor of the month award to Lord
Bach mood AKA Lord wait wait hey put
your hands together damn it let's go
appreciate it guys appreciate it you
know I can't believe it's almost been
like three years since I joined lockdown
my time flies and so it's a great honor
I'm really happy to you know uh to lead
and just to help and learn from everyone
from the team so thank you for this
opportunity and I look forward just to
the Future so thank you everybody
brother man appreciate it brother you
know one of your my favorite articles
when you kind of showed how buying
consoles internationally are
it's one of my favorite articles for me
because you know we sometimes Gamers we
live in a box and we don't understand
how things are and like how hard it is
and you had the fixes you had you would
show like how to knock off see it is out
there certain things it was so cool man
bro I love your energy I don't think you
get enough credit you're criminal you
don't want nobody buying a face station
but now the thing about you what people
always tell me like they love going to
you for advice you know what I'm saying
as far as your style and even attic man
with the with the reviews you guys do
without the walkthroughs and the tips
salute to you brother tremendous want to
give you appreciation no doubt hit up
saw also been hit up solve as well get
y'all merge get anything for free we
gotta reward the scribes and the editors
at long neck my Bros salute to y'all man
thank y'all so much blessing thank you
thank you so we got the business taken
care of we all good let's get a couple
super chats they get all cause Johnny
Black Adam I mean and and um
Let's see we got Stitch remember for 36
months so what do you all think about
what Sony is doing to prevent cross play
the new card has a disabled cross play
option on the PlayStation but not Xbox
or PC also if the option is off 2xp is
active constantly on Playstation they've
been incentivizing you to keep it off
then I want you to be in the closet
don't play with others look at the other
day I do you know say the the um I do
like the option to not have cross play
though if you don't want it I do like
that so Xbox got to figure that out
because then why they gotta give them
incentive not to play with us no but
sometimes play with them Xbox it said
certain games certain games some
exploitation happening in certain things
people with a complete experience yeah
the explosion of us knowing that we
going at 60 and you're going at 40.
anyway moving on I I'm actually
Pro taking PC out of cues and just have
consoles versus consoles of PC versus PC
yeah um
sorry well at this point I
even in options okay but it's just like
they gotta make
the default console versus console and
not PC like you have to turn that on
because I feel like a lot of people
don't even know and they're having bad
experiences uh apparently war zone like
the past couple months had like horrible
cheating
and like there's I know a few people
that just stopped playing and there's
been a bunch of streamers that just
stopped playing it and it's just like
look like sure there is cheating that
goes on on consoles but it's not even
remotely as bad as it is on PC like in
nowhere near I feel I think
unfortunately we'll lose that battle
just for engagement these companies want
the most to hire player pool but I agree
that you know hopefully you know I don't
know because um I feel like it's like a
give and take and yeah companies will
only take so much before they before
they do it because we've seen like sea
thieves completely remove the eye you
can't even play with PC people anymore I
don't really I don't know like they they
have been doing certain things but it's
just like you know if you want
to do this PC console everyone plays
together like first off there
I think it works more better with
Playstation Xbox in some cases switch
then it works with PC because there's so
many options over there and there might
be like there's a giant gate on console
and it's harder to get through that gate
on Console to cheat on PC you got people
that just climb over the gate blow up
the gate like I get it I get it
he got bars he's crazy today but I feel
like as long as it took me as long as
they got the option I'm cool but um
anyway we got to switch as we all
finished on that and someone yeah
anything else no we got really good to
go let me do this God of War giveaway
yes please please please okay I forgot
about that
all right let me go ahead and share my
screen yes
what version are you giving away
this is a collector's edition I think it
should have both we'll see right so I
use this website it's called a Twitter
picker
what what it does is I loaded the tweet
it will go from this tweet and it will
uh it will pick someone that has
followed all these accounts now Lords of
gaming.net supposed to be here too but
it won't let me there's not enough
characters I said you had to have a
picture unfortunately because there's
too many people you know we can uncheck
that one because I have you got to have
an account for six months in a banner uh
but so all right so we'll go ahead and
do this what's funny is after you do all
that only 133 people actually did the
Tweet said yeah
all right so let's do this
boy who getting that boy
oh young Taz yo I know Taz Oh Taz got it
yeah
this dude this dude
yeah you didn't follow the king and you
didn't get it
following me
no no no
okay okay
by the end of this podcast I should have
500 more followers
for you it felt like they were on the
read a couple of the tweet and after
that they just stopped following them
and it's just like look man like there
was like five or six one but it's like
we're giving like 100 plus dollars of a
merchandise away so it's just like and
what's funny is where I said you have to
have your account for six months like
because that it's just like at the end
of the day like I feel like that's a
good
a good number it's like people can't
people can't like cheat the system
Christopher you wasn't getting it anyway
because you want to support the dev so
you go buy it
I will say and I I don't know if Saul
Cog and King can agree but I will say
that it I would consider that successful
you know it did a good engagement level
so I would say we'll be doing more of
those Twitter games I loved it I love
the fact that the dude could have won
but he wasn't following me
three people what a cheeky guy he's like
I'm not I'm not gonna follow these guys
yeah but I would still win I still win
because their system isn't sophisticated
so they won't know
right yeah
um
I guess I should have checked ties to
see if he was following lordsagaming.net
but I can't I can't hate on someone that
the system couldn't let me check them
yeah but I'm pretty sure Ty's is
following them anyway so it doesn't
matter yeah so Taza get at me with your
information remember uh you know you're
not gonna get it for lunch so if you
want to wait cool if not uh don't
worry.net I just look yeah cool by the
way is that actually like the physical
yeah
I think the jotinar Edition
it's the one down we couldn't get the
joke
okay okay
I think it's got a hammer the jolte came
with something else something else oh no
that one came with the um the bone dice
All Right
Moving On
let's get this Joy popping all right you
can't like now they're following me
you lost out that we've gotten to what
the uh Lord's been playing giveaways log
that and everything else we got to
switch our Focus to our patient guests
Lord Johnny his video game system
history his journey into software
engineering being a musician and of
course what led him to the Jolly plays
live content channel so Lord John let's
start from the very beginning what was
some of the first video game systems you
had and what got you into gaming I love
that question my very first system was
uh the Super Nintendo so by the way for
context I'm from 88. so I'm 34 years old
uh so the super ninta and I was raised
in Brazil maybe that's useful because
consoles are different in different
countries yeah yeah so back then
the Super Nintendo was kind of what you
could get we didn't really have access
to Sega that much actually yeah
so so I got my hands on that I remember
playing my favorite game ever on that
console was the the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles game you know the one where
you're like traveling all over time and
yeah
y'all know that one yeah yeah so I got
my ass kicked on that one but I loved it
um and yeah I I never got into Super
Mario for some reason but I did play a
whole bunch of other games like X-Men oh
you got a thing against plumbers
too Italian for me
[Laughter]
no no what else would I want to give me
some other standouts man if you had or
remember did you play Castlevania I did
not that's one of the like flagrant
fragrant big gaps okay I'm trying to be
fancy one of the big gaps in my uh yeah
in my play history
Super Nintendo so they're from there any
other what was like the next progression
from a concert so that was interesting
actually didn't have consoles for quite
a while I played like emulator games on
my PC we didn't have a lot of money so
like I played a lot of Game Boy games on
PC emulator and stuff like that and then
some years later when I moved to Spain I
actually had my first console after that
which was the the PlayStation one so at
the time because where I lived everybody
just had PlayStations I don't know like
a regional thing you know it's like that
sometimes right so I got a PlayStation
one and that's where I played my
favorite RPG of all time which is Final
Fantasy 7.
great guy
started I was like oh yeah see you guys
I'll see you guys next week
let me ask you a question did you um
when you were purchasing the game did
you know it was a RPG or did you think
it was an action game dude I didn't know
what the hell it was honestly yeah it
was a friend of mine and I'm ashamed to
say it was even a pirated copy because
at the
stop snitching right
read the mug
so yeah so this friend brought over the
game and said listen
try this out it's weird and different
but I think you're gonna love it and he
wasn't wrong at first I was like what is
this it's weird right but once you get
into it and you kind of oh yeah it just
sucked me into it and then introduced me
to RPG games
to be just engrossed in a story and
stuff like that great music oh music the
cinematics like you said it was a a very
introductory piece to a a lot of Gamers
who never even yeah touched that genre
before right and seeing that you could
tell these kind of great stories so it's
interesting to see I wanted to back up
one quick second because I don't I
wanted to ask you from I know you went
from Brazil to Spain but I wanted to ask
a little bit about the the Brazil gaming
scene I know you were younger then but
do you remember anything specific in
pertaining to how different it was when
you went to Spain well back then so this
was before the year 2000 that I was in
Brazil so
needless to say gaming was still kind of
in its early days back then it was kind
of a very Niche thing right and where I
lived people playing games were playing
them on Game Boy
they had maybe they had a Super Nintendo
at home but I would say like 90 of kids
they would have their fancy Game Boy
which I was so jealous right because I
couldn't afford one so I would see these
these kids a lot of kids they're fancy
and at some point I got the normal Game
Boy and then these guys got the calling
oh so you sit there with them
so I have to see all these guys playing
Pokemon in the color one black and white
ah okay I know you were young but but
um obviously the price thing has always
been a big conversation point in Brazil
do you remember them being excessively
expensive over there
yeah man uh especially like the Game Boy
I remember yeah it was a good chunk of
money I don't know like it's hard to
compare with like nowadays money right
because everything is so different right
my feeling to give you an indication is
that it would be something like 200 the
feel of it in terms of like a very meaty
one that's expensive yeah yeah yeah and
then
I I had to Market that to my parents
right like hey guys like
it's interesting that you say super
Nintendo's what you had too because uh a
lot of the story around Sega in in
Brazil was that Sega was big in Brazil
because again Brazil would Brazil would
get a lot of stuff super late so Sega
was you know on it kind of it's on its
way out but you know in the early 2000s
we're looking at the Sega Saturn over
here go you know the end of the Sega
Saturn we're looking at the Dreamcast
and over there
I like the Master System the the Genesis
lasted super long in Brazil because
again they had an extra long tail
because of the price like you could a
brand new console like if you wanted to
keep up with the consoles you were
looking at uh like a thousand dollar
investment to get that console when it
was out over here so yeah I think that I
was not in the like hardcore gamer yeah
Niche yet I was very much like a casual
gotcha you know like that was my Gateway
into gaming really and that's just
because I think Nintendo kind of spoke
to a broader audience at the time
especially with the Game Boy and stuff
like that and so I was just aware of
that one I actually never heard of Sega
until many years later wow and okay
um and then yeah for reasons I just
couldn't get a console at that time
they don't got a handheld yeah I care
about this game boy that everybody got
yeah I just want to play Pokemon in
color that was me back then yeah so then
obviously out of your Spade he said
PlayStation now you get your bigger
question real quick is what was your
starter in the original Pokemon
okay so my first Pokemon Red that was my
first Pokemon game right okay and I went
Charmander because in my mind
damn no no hear me out right okay I have
three options my dude one of them causes
little plants
is the correct Choice the other one
squirts a little water on the enemy and
the third one spits fire hello
you like Spitfire yeah yeah listen in
fact he spit high five you gotta you got
a rip shot
fire I I don't accept that answer
I can't believe it
that's the one you like yeah okay
foreign
he was going to destroy that Charmander
so and I have to admit I in hindsight I
think Squirtle had the best personality
so oh man
the best personality
called you you've seen Charizard you
just don't know what his name is the big
red dragon
with a little fire on his tail
Dragon right he's actually a dragon
about that little water guy that Dragon
though you know what's funny like like
growing up you don't realize that
Charizard is not that tall like at all
you know you're not wrong
is actually smaller than it looks and
Squirtle the water dude his evolution is
pretty badass because he's like he's got
cannons he's a big turtle right nobody
want no Turtle we want to yell out
jakaris
I think you're being a little you're
doing him dirty
yeah yeah
nobody comes up to you and say yo buddy
I got a a turtle that spit water
and I got a baby dragon
you don't you don't sell it like that
though you have a better yeah
anyway moving on so yes you had that and
then oh we got into the PlayStation
ecosystem Final Fantasy VII now again
you still stay with console did you move
on like what was the next progression
for the longest time I stayed with with
consoles until the year
2007. okay and uh I'm getting old so I'm
getting my ears confused but I'm pretty
sure 2007 I started University and
that's where I opened up to like PC
gaming I had done so this is where
things went wrong okay yeah this is
where yeah this is where they got me
um so until then I had played like Age
of Empires 2 on PC and stuff like that
but kind of small stuff right
um and then that's where it opened up
like oh I can play with people right I
can play [ __ ] online with people but I
got into dude I got into Warcraft 3.
here we go there's some maps with people
here we go oh that was the [ __ ]
the sponsors
Warcraft right he got into Warcraft yeah
and it's always a moment that we realize
us Warcraft players realize our soul has
been sucked two long pause uh what what
made you get because obviously you made
it out of the dark side what made you
give up Warcraft
okay so one big distinction is I never
got into and by the way sorry for
cussing it's I'm kind of used to it on
the other podcast
you came from we're gonna talk about
that
so sorry about that to be fair it took
ACG like three or four yeah
keep it clean I'll keep it clean keep it
clean but um so the distinction is I
never got into World of Warcraft which I
think is the the more
difficult one could jump out of yeah
yeah it's like a dick really I had a
friend that had heavy addiction to that
yeah yes it is he lost his like degree
in University
[Music]
damn now he's a master a master Mage oh
oh man yeah I don't know if that pays
it pays World of Warcraft
it does the people see farming gold at
the time maybe yes but but I'll tell you
what there was a gateway
uh and I definitely had some addiction
phases where it was a bit compulsive but
I've brought it back I've brought it
back but um it was a Gateway into other
games in the MOBA sphere so you know uh
DOTA nice Heroes of new Earth League of
Legends and uh currently I'm playing
League of Legends but I've kind of
jumped between many of those and it's
always been a really fun type of game
for me to play so it's kind of stayed
with me in a way
nice nice salute me I love it love the
journey there and then uh I know we're
gonna fast forward a little bit but I
wanted to also pivot so again stay on PC
now at what that point when you're in PC
you get into the movie and all that you
know at that point is it predominantly
or you're still doing kind of
multi-platform
or wherever good games go you follow or
PC kind of you know appreciates you at
that point well no it was a mix in fact
all of my single player gaming was on
Console at the time so I I remember a
you know Cherished Memories like playing
LA Noire I love that game I still need
to go back and play that it's such a gem
you know and then oh maybe one of my
favorites Mass Effect
which one uh from the three yeah I would
say
it's a difficult one because Mass Effect
1 for me is the best story right and
that's the one that pulled me in right
right and it was an amazing just
immersive stop being diplomatic which
one
okay it is number one however just a
caveat right the caveat is that the
gameplay got a lot better in number two
it's it's very crusty very crusty
they're very very crunchy actually
coming from someone that you know
dabbled in the mass effects but never
beat them I actually prefer three over
one and two that's really interesting
yeah because obviously people
no I don't say interesting like very
interesting for your young mind that's
that's a real that's a real interesting
take for the youngest
I think it goes I personally think it
goes three two one because I I feel like
you know that game play but I don't know
why maybe it's but here's the thing the
reason three was so good is because they
did such a good job building a world two
three
we have to admit yeah one absolutely I'm
a two guy but one set the stage of this
because three was just like the moment
it started it never stopped like that
whole game yes
sadly it did end and it did end in yes
yes
so here's the thing Johnny we got to get
proper context for the for the younger
Lord is that he's now joining the series
after like he just played Mass Effect
for the first time like last year the
whole Trojan okay so the perspective
interesting and oh wow
I got context that I actually want to
ask since you know people say this what
happened if you could rewrite any of
these two stories which one the original
uh Game of Thrones franchise or Mass
Effect
you know what I'm gonna say Game of
Thrones because the thing with Mass
Effect right it's actually an awesome
game yes until that point yes it's just
that the ending sours it for you for
many people yeah and I think that's a
shame however I'll also say for a lot of
people like myself I care more about my
memory during a game
yeah the journey over destination right
right so for me I can still really
appreciate number three whereas a lot of
other people kind of totally put it
inside just because they didn't like
that that's a good point and give added
credit because I don't feel like we you
know but to give us credit I love
listening to him as a first-time player
of the series it is an interesting right
now no uh no sarcasm yeah it is
interesting it was because I was like to
see a new player play this beloved
series of us and what his perspective is
right and to hear him you know talk
about how he loved the build up you know
I told him how obviously you know he
knows I'm a two fan but you know how
three really captivated him you know I'm
saying and the ending didn't hit as like
negatively as it hit us but granted
Beverly we we he had the the benefit of
the additional add-ons they made to the
ending that we didn't have when the game
first ended when three ended at the time
it came out even with the add-on the
ending was so horrible like
my biggest downfall that I felt like
that game had is it's like my biggest
one I know it had a lot of them but that
that thing that you saved in the first
one the the plant life or whatever it is
the queen yeah I'm like you don't see
that thing again to the third one and
after you do that story again with the
it really never showed back up like so
it's like you do all this and it it's
like look like obviously that third one
was pushed out
um you know Matt I honestly felt like
they could have took the time kind of
like what Resident Evil 2 and uh three
and you know now four to build that up
and they should have fixed it with the
remasters so yeah it's a controversial
thing but uh yeah
congratulations
but anyway so basically you did
multi-platform and then like I said you
still did your single player experiences
or console and pretty much been picking
up pretty much everything gaming wise
since I would assume
yeah yeah exactly nowadays I do a lot on
PC just because I have a a beastly
machine Flex yeah flexible you have a
little flex and he looked over at it
like
38 over there
oh I have a 39 year old look at that
dirty 90 of pocket I shift out for the
3090 in my defense
there wasn't the 3080 available at the
time it was like the the crazy times
when you just couldn't get your hands on
that card so I just went for the no
that's right it's a bigger better more
money down let's go big boys
I called it an investment dude I mean
it's better than Justified but at the
end of the day it is what it is nothing
Into Your Love No Doubt for sure now you
got to do it you got to do it so
transitioning now obviously the gaming
background tremendous you know but one
thing that's really cool about you is
software engineer what kind of fuel that
passion career was
okay so here's what's super interesting
I had no idea
uh that I was gonna like it or that I
was into it to begin with okay let me
let me put you in my shoes at the time I
had no idea what to do all I knew was I
wanted to go to university
and that I wanted to do something in the
realm of engineering but I mean there
are so many options in there so very
right so very yeah that's what I thought
I would do that's why I would ask you
these questions yeah exactly so my dad
was trained as a civil engineer and so
that's where I kind of got it you know I
want that mindset because I like that
about him but I didn't know like what
specifically to do and my whole decision
making this was me at 18 so don't judge
me go let's go
know what to do but
I can't draw at all okay right I
absolutely suck at drawing or anything
like technical drawing or stuff like
that the perspective so I I can't do
many of the trades that need yeah that's
requested and I'm like I'm pretty good
with computers okay you know I'm gonna
get into this and it's gonna be great
however that's a really terrible
decision making process because you know
the degree has nothing to do with using
computers at a user level right it's
it's like programming and stuff like
that oh yeah but
well just to wrap it up like once I got
into it I I saw this kind of algorithmic
mindset this thinking the problem
solving that completely
um
absorbed me it was like a different way
of thinking about stuff
analytical problem solving that uh I was
able to kind of apply to other stuff so
it was really transformational but I
just got lucky I had no idea I was gonna
like it and I just went into it slow it
that is tremendous it's like the
definition jumping head first oh yeah
first and then finding out that you have
that passion for it right and then
really just keep going it was kind of
like developing the passion like it
wasn't there initially at all right I
kind of sucked at it it took a long time
for me to get my feet under under me but
um I think it's one of those things I
don't know about you guys but you find
something difficult that you suck at and
you're not naturally good at it but it's
interesting enough that you kind of keep
at it yeah and then over time you
develop that passion but it's not really
there initially because since you're not
good at it it doesn't feel that good
yeah it don't feel silly right yeah
there's little breakthroughs that you
get in those moments and you're like
okay and then when things finally start
to click and you get a little bit more
comfortable it really starts to take
take shape and yeah that's pretty cool
man the other thing I want to talk about
that you know is people don't know about
you is that you know see those amazing
guitars behind you yes sir that's what I
wanted to get to musical composers man
let me tell you this bad guy albums
man's got albums out right now man you
know sick instrumentals uh you got a
drink right now that I'm loving it it's
called um Unstoppable I was listening to
it that's that's right man I appreciate
that fired like I love your instrumental
game so like tell me how this aspect of
Johnny is creating this is unique so
throughout my whole university days I've
always been in bands and well I started
playing in my teens so since I was 14
years old I was playing the guitar nice
and yeah my mom and dad got me a Fender
Stratocaster when I was 14. well it was
a squire it was a you know a cheap one
yo you stupid
because
he's ridiculous at the time I was
imbibing like Red Hot Chili Peppers and
this sort of stuff right just the
Striking guitar yeah and I was like I
wanna do that
um and then I got into that in
University I just found I was lucky I
found people who were also into similar
types of music at the time I was doing a
lot of like punk rock and stuff like
that and a little bit of metal
um who's your guitar Idol
it would have to be John Frusciante from
Red Hot Chili Peppers just because
the way I play was very inspired by that
um
yes I'd have to give him the you know
the the incredible credit but anyway
long story short I I played concerts
with bands throughout my University days
and got some uh some exposure to the
kind of the the drug like feeling of
attention right
attention from the girls
can you show me your CDs
yeah I was a bit of a misfit during high
school I just knew it wasn't my time you
know it's one of those things yeah this
wasn't my time in high school uh I kind
of was a bit of a late bloomer and that
was my time
the music is just right with the music
stuff
connected with people a lot I bet you
did connect with people that's when he's
programming actually yeah
he was able to program after that
like in anime after something like that
happens you like you your powers are oh
yeah
it was over 900.
title four
there's this magical saying with music I
don't know if do any of you uh play or
no no I listen very well
[Music]
no that's awesome but what's super
interesting that I didn't know until
those days is that it's like a universal
language man I because you know
throughout my masters and stuff I would
play with someone with whom I had never
talked before Oh that day and we could
play dude like
like we could we could Jam not not like
a known song or anything we could
actually just kind of communicate
through music so that was awesome yeah
so it's always been a big part of uh
my interests and what drives me a way to
process that's fine stuff right so is it
like when something bad happens that was
always a way for me to kind of process
that and get through it yeah no that's
dope man I'm putting your links to the
album in the chat oh man I really
appreciate it but with that bad Camp
y'all I'm gonna tell you right now my
personal job I ran over the city and I
was like yeah
we have a multi-platinum artist yeah we
got the artist in the building Soul
companion is the album that I was
jamming to you know what I'm saying I
was kicking up his intro I was like yo I
like this joke and shout out to the
artwork on that I love the artworks oh
thanks yeah I did work with an awesome
artist for that and by the way uh the
music is also on Spotify
yeah if people if people check out my
Twitter yeah there will be a link to
okay that at the very top and you can
check it out for free I would love for
people to you know share some thoughts
let's promote that let's promote that
that's part of the beauty too is hearing
back from people who listen to your
songs and kind of yeah get stuff so I'll
put it up there on Johnny plays that
live you go there on his channel right
there have all the audio set section and
all that and check that out you know
what I'm saying man the man's Got Talent
you know what I'm saying so we got that
you got all this stuff you got the
position there you get yourself for
engineering Lord Johnny why in the hell
you got into this gaming content
creation business
what possessed you the best with this
stuff here so
I saw someone doing a Let's Play One Day
right
um and he's now a big YouTuber
um north of Northern lion oops I think
he's he was called back doesn't matter
he does Let's Plays
and I saw that and for some reason I was
like I will you know
it's one of those like I wanna do that
does that ever happened to you guys like
you see someone doing something and you
go like dude I want to do that that's
cool yes and I felt like I could do it
and I would you know do it well or or
have a good time doing it so that's why
I got into it man and then from there
initially I was just doing let's plays
on YouTube and you know it was fun but
the the live interaction like you guys
have here like you know real people
chiming in right they're like uh talking
stuff back at you it's just another
level of connecting with people beyond
your immediate real life circles yes
because let's be honest it's a bit of a
lottery yeah
you can meet some great people but
finding people who connect with you at
different levels in real life is
difficult for sure and so widening the
circle yeah to more and more people
online I think is a beautiful way to
gravitate towards
communities and stuff like that so
that's kind of where he was born man no
salute to you man like again definitely
know exactly what you mean you start to
see it you know I was pulled in by
addict and bro you are good yeah yeah
you listening to it right I told you
yeah bro you listen to that music
I just got goosebumps he's really good
bro like I was I was zoning out and I
think you know who's gonna like it when
he comes back addict because addict's a
person who sometimes he doesn't like a
lot of heavy lyrical stuff you know he
just likes nice instrumental things on
your on the music side and I think he'll
like so I put that specific Link in the
chat are you like Final Fantasy VII I
mean I'm gonna tell you man you gave me
you gave that the first song I was
listening to gave me battle Vibes like
like yeah like okay
the hair standing up along real battle
Vibes salute to that the contact
creation the streaming you know I saw
your grounded review high quality love
the way you you're very informative
style and then obviously the live stream
but that is also on the podcasting you
know saying and how yeah you know I came
across you you know I mean was actually
one of the best gaming podcasts shout
out to our best friend and host Lord AC
friendly competition by the way we're
not saying we're better you know you're
not saying you're back you're just the
best damn gaming podcast I mean you're
not just humble with it y'all just
humble with it that was salute to the
team that's with everybody over there
and uh yeah so how did that relationship
as far as like linking up with ACG start
it's a bit of a Cinderella Story man
let's go because what what happened is
you know I was doing the Let's Plays and
stuff and I would listen to the ACG
reviews and they were just you know
really high value reviews that you
really enjoyed the way he presented data
and stuff like that and that was the
first time I actually went to patreon
and I was like you know what I'm gonna
you know I'm gonna get in there pitching
a couple bucks and I saw oh he's got a
Discord I didn't use Discord before then
so this was now five years ago or
something yeah yeah so I was like I'm
gonna check that out right so I go in
there and I kind of figure out what it
is over time we start doing a bit of
voice chats sometimes and I was
surprised because I would see you know
the men himself Carrick yes in the voice
chat and I'd be like wait so I can just
jump in there and talk to him yeah
that's fine I had a bit of like uh uh
Stars right yeah with your Heroes jump
in there and you're like dude you're a
celebrity to me and then like I can just
chat with you and he was super
approachable
um it was it was a bit of a life lesson
to see that at the end of the day it's
just people right behind the big stuff
that you like and so going in there
seeing he's just a dude an awesome dude
to chat with and um initially it was it
was we didn't quite get along because my
English wasn't that good I think I came
across as a bit argumentative
over time we found our groove I found my
groove with the language too because it
you know it's not my first language and
then
uh we we kind of started having so super
cool conversations we would talk about
wild stuff like AI science you know like
all this random stuff I love it yeah
um and then from there he he invited me
to the podcast as a guest one time and
then I had a follow-up and then after
that and we kept chatting voice chats he
said listen man do you want to be a
regular member he was like I do you know
those moments where you pretend to keep
your cool
face up Poker Face I'm like yeah that'd
be pretty cool
you want to go steady yeah
that'd be pretty cool inside I'm losing
losing my thing that's fire man
like you said too because the down the
Earth nature of them you know he's super
approachable you know that's one of the
things that we respect to you know for
people was because you know in this game
we've seen you know there's a lot of
sometimes Hollywood people yeah it's a
lot of Hollywood behavior and people
forget to you know respond to your
messages and stuff but you know yeah I
leave you unseen yeah but you know he's
always been true for with the Lord and
and I respect him so much man he's
really he's really done a lot for us we
we've worked together it's Fab so yeah
if the gaming community in general had
acg's approach this the community in the
gaming industry in general would be in a
lot better place and what I love that he
does similar to the Lord is like we try
to uplift others and it's not we're not
playing this numbers game oh you gotta
have yeah before we could deal with you
I like it because also your approach and
the way you you know you welcome me
another guest here it's really like a
zero-sum game yeah for you you don't
view it as oh you know if if this person
is getting a viewer it means I'm losing
one it's like the pie is not limited in
a way you know people are jumping into
the game the whole time so
um it really is like amplifying others
also amplifies yourself absolutely oh
yeah absolutely and I don't play guitar
so if anybody can get over here
yeah you better do it doubt I salute
love to hear that [ __ ] guys do the best
game podcast love that joint last thing
I want to say also too is um one thing I
really expect about you is that
obviously you have fun on video and
stream but uh before we started the even
required today we got to talk about the
real star of the channel
basil the cat
so what did the basil takeover begin and
your channel is heavily themed for Basil
the cat so we got it again yes let's go
so
um it is irrelevant actually because
four years ago I got my own place so
that was a huge kind of victory for me
moving from the the renting yeah to even
if it's in a mortgage like ownership
right yeah so it was a big victory like
milestone for me and what I said was
because they don't let you have pets if
you're renting here in London right so
what I said was and I grew up having
cats a lot so I loved cats so I was like
okay the moment I have my own place
I'm gonna have a cat and that's gonna be
this yeah yeah it's gonna be like a
physical symbol of my my accomplishment
of my achievement my accomplishment and
so in a way he's like the embodiment of
that Victory and that's why I also
wanted to make him a big part of like my
channel because I started the the twitch
channel uh at that time too because it's
when I you know when I moved I then had
good internet and I could start actually
streaming instead of just doing YouTube
and so it all kind of started together
and it just felt right to use that as my
symbol you know like Batman
[Laughter]
absolute man that is absolutely classic
well I gotta give people a shout out
because I think you put something on
Twitter one time to actually have me
dying where you were playing uh straight
or PlayStation and he's going crazy for
the like yo what's going on he going up
on the screen what's going on with my
brother's house yeah
the cat on screen of the noises he would
go crazy
absolutely hilarious no doubt a new
segment for Lord attic I wanted to ask
you so where did Lord Johnny um finding
find us where's your first time here
about IOP
well it's been a while now that I've
been following you guys I think the
first time Carrick told me about you
guys ACG yeah he was like yo these guys
are legit check it out
um and yeah I've been definitely
watching in the just lurking yeah
much appreciated brother no doubt and we
got to ask the question we asked every
guest in the realm tradition this might
be hard yeah I'm dying to know this from
him Lord Johnny's top five video games
or franchises of all time your personal
picks
do you prefer I give you a whole
franchise or an actual specification
this is you whatever you go specific you
can go Fred anything you want to do
um well I'm gonna get granular okay
gonna get granular it's not doing
franchises let's get to it let's get to
it okay
favorite game ever uh Final Fantasy VII
let's go I understand uh some people
might say if you played it today it
wouldn't be as good right but the fact
is I didn't play it today I played it
back then and it was the best thing I
you know I played on and it kind of
shaped me in so many ways to this day I
listen to that sound oh bro very regular
bro I still got the soundtrack rocket
did you get the remix soundtrack did you
get the rebate soundtrack
I have it oh it's five yeah that's
fantastic the Remake came out oh yeah
yeah don't do that don't do that
it's distasteful
I mean
he was disgusting
yeah yeah there's a couple of Beats that
I bro that Joy is [ __ ] I can't wait to
play because you're beta testing it
right now you're stupid
the sephirothy was crazy too yeah we
will get into it but anyway so we got
yeah okay what else okay
um I'm gonna go with Final Fantasy 10
that's my second one so but I do like
Final Fantasy A lot but I'm actually not
a huge jrpg person it might surprise me
so it's just that some of those games
really captured me and then like yeah
the RPG aspect do you approve final five
I think 10 is so underrated like what it
is is people love to put up the the
video of Titus like hysterically
laughing for no reason and then act like
that's the whole game
they're trying to clown it like yeah the
problem is that his name is actually
Titus not true he'd be cool if his name
was Titus but his name was never known
how to pronounce his name honestly I'll
pronounce the thing however I want to
song
you will pronounce it as Titus
I didn't even realize so we got 557
Final Fantasy 10 that's two well yeah
let's get regular
my third favorite game has to be
this is a hard one but I'm just gonna
say in general
DOTA oh okay first donut in the room
DOTA Dota 2 yeah um I would put League
of Legends in there right now I actually
like it more than I did DOTA but it's
just that I played five thousand hours
back in the day of DOTA so it's kind of
like a foundational game so let me go to
a league both or League replaces DOTA 5
000 hours of DOTA two okay and then
recently so I then completely dropped
DOTA okay and recently this year I've
played for about a year league okay uh
in my off time so league is your number
four pick but or no
that's a tough I can't squeeze it in
there that's not fair I'm gonna put it
in number four okay okay number four
League of Legends got you
number five round it out this is this is
where it gets really tricky because a
lot of titles are competing here yes I
got like really action-y stuff that I
love and so I have a lot of stuff but I
have to plug in here uh Elden ring
[Music]
all right
we didn't get to talk about this but I'm
a huge Souls fan so I've played all the
souls right and love those games and in
a way I view Elden ring as the
culmination like the final iteration of
all those games because if you've played
them you kind of get this feeling that
they're iterating over the same formula
right you have like one two okay win a
different way bring it back three
polished iteration of the game
um and you have some other games like
Sakira which are different and stuff
like that but Elden ring really feels
like bringing all of it under the same
realm
um as you guys say yeah and just kind of
yes
your expression like people who like
Sakura were brought in people who liked
Dark Souls 3 were also brought in the
open world gang who didn't like Souls
also kind of Blended in with everybody
they got a new base yeah you got a new
base oh I can play this game with magic
if I don't want to mess about with the
Perry
I might have the unpopular opinion but I
think Sakura is a better overall game I
think it's an extremely polished
and if you like what it's doing
there's really no second to it because
just the pace the frenetic pace of the
fights is so engrossing right when you
get into the rhythm of parrying and
attacking and stuff there's something
really rhythmic about it yeah I think no
other game does that game does a very
good job at emerging a boss fight that
very fuse actually ever been able to do
successfully I will say though I
personally like
to choose my play style and I think
Elden ring allows you that whereas
Sakira your you know your roll cast
right your Typecast into the deflecting
play style got it no fair enough great
great example and obviously we see when
Alden ring how it just transform you
know the the whole Zeitgeist you know at
the top of the year it was just
absolutely everywhere in the sea not of
non-souls people pick up Elder ring as
their first game and become addicted to
the genre now like yep it's it's that
formative you know so gotta I got a
better knee on that and give give it
flowers it's going to be interesting
it's it's killing Cog to say that it's
not
for me but I I'm not a Souls guy but I
always recognize when something is
moving when something is doing something
it's just you know what's funny that
game
that game is so successful what it did
it's the only game that saw bought four
copies of for iops we have never done
that
no never never and it was that thing of
like yeah even Kai even Cog after he
played it he was like okay it's not for
me but I get it if I get it yeah and and
the thing about I what I think what
Johnny talks about perfectly and why I
think it's still going to be Game of the
Year regardless
it's just that that game the fact that
unlike Souls like if you're not the
greatest player you couldn't like once
those you can grind right but what you
can grind and when you get to a certain
point if you can't pass that point
you're done till you pass that point and
in Eldon Reign you're just like okay I'm
gonna go this way
yeah and and that is the that is as true
of an open world as you're ever going to
see that breath of the wild things like
that but it really is the the true
sandbox I agree I think
yeah I don't know which any other game
does that I said I think what makes
um out and ring so successful is they
found a way to casualize their gameplay
without casualizing their gameplay
when you start you could literally okay
I wanna I wanna do okay where's the
moonville's gonna be the exact same
place and you could go get it off the
Gap off the start like you don't you
don't have to do now sure you might go
you might struggle getting it but it's
like you you have a lot of accessibility
in how you want to play and at any time
if you want to play with a certain build
you could go get the the ingredients to
that build at any time in the game yeah
yeah yes I brought to the wild thing
where you come out into the opening you
know the great plane and you're like all
right I can go right to Gannon
breath of the wild is more
open than Elden ring is because half the
map is blocked at the beginning of Edwin
right like you can't get to the other
half but breath of wild you can start
anywhere and go anywhere in the game so
I had to give that to breath of the wild
but you know it's still the worst not a
game ever made oh my God so
um yeah so tremendous five right there
and the final question for Lord Johnny
favorite console of all time and why
I think
that's a difficult one how do you guys
think about
you know Nostalgia versus currently
because obviously yeah consoles nowadays
would kick the ass or an older console
but do we think about it in terms of
like the good times you've had with it I
think you go you could go about it I'm
sorry no you can go out both ways but I
think time and place is really important
because it's not fair to be like yeah
the the the the the NES
it's not fair I I beg to differ oh okay
I begged it different I beg the
difference in this uh in this thought
right
games are
subjective to your emotions and your
feeling at that time it doesn't have
anything to do with the technical Powers
around the game or whatever machine is
actually playing it it has everything to
do with how that game interacts with you
at that moment right so the reason why I
asked you about Castlevania early is
because when I put Castlevania on in
Nintendo 64. I mean um I mean Super NES
it transformed what I thought about
Castlevania right so it it I can
literally if I would have had that same
experience new experience with that game
and I have a PlayStation 5 right now and
I I have the wealth of the games that
they have now but if I could take that
experience that same experience with the
Nintendo 6D I mean NES
it didn't matter if it was on Old
Hardware right so that would transport
me to that moment so when we asked what
is your greatest console it has to
probably do with your greatest
experiences your Collective experiences
at a moment that you feel not the
technical powers of submissions some of
my best machines is the worst machines
good yeah okay so that that's a good
framing uh so the way that I would say
it even though I've had amazing times
with the Xbox like Mass Effect I just
cherish those things right
um I think it's still like PlayStation
one because jump because if you remember
what I told you like the jump was from
Super NES
Playstation One what yeah
it's a wild jump huge music I suddenly
was playing Dino Crisis
yo games can do this I didn't know that
right so it was the the first console
that just ignited my uh my love for
games really no I'm glad you said Place
PlayStation one PlayStation yeah that
that was the classic square one I also
had the slim but yes but the first one
though right yeah it was transformative
that uh sorry guys I just I long for
that PlayStation
the charm he brought up Dino Crisis with
tremendous was a Resident Evil on that
tremendous you know it was the the jump
from 2D to 3D was transformative as king
mentioned the CD you know really taking
shape and music and gaming and obviously
you mentioned Final Fantasy VII and the
impact there there were a lot of first
that Gamers were introducing like you
said that jump right where he's like
okay this is a significant difference
from what I was playing during the 2D
era and stuff like that transformative
yes yes it was it was they it was
something special I have a a special
affinity for PlayStation one that's
honestly my favorite PlayStation console
there's no doubt so we share that so uh
yeah awesome tremendous history I know
we've gone long I know we're getting
close out there you see you gotta give
me three but just let me know if you if
I'm I'm hitting time for you you're
talking I'm okay one more time all right
no doubt no doubt no doubt so we're
gonna get into the poll you know what
I'm saying or you saw everyone get the
super chats first or yeah
she got a couple that said hold on
they're about to get crazy now you don't
forget what this weekend represents
oh we got hard to find member for 19
months Lord bronze assalamu alaikum my
brothers good to see
combat talk was great as always and Cog
where do you want to sit at the Super
Bowl hashtag Niners yeah you got us
there okay listen we gotta win some
games man guys just Jimmy Ruffalo got
stuff
and obviously my Jets might have
something oh yeah yeah
right now we're down by three but um
I got a better record than us so we
can't hear you know the deflating balls
again though about a different language
right now don't worry about it I do know
what the Super Bowl is though so like
pat on the back there
moving on yeah we gotta put the crest in
the chat for mad for 10 manager for 10
member for two years but welcome to Lord
bronze thank you so thank you brother
thank you I think we got hard to find
once again five dollars which has
Squirtle and getting your soul sucked is
what I walked into today only on IOP
hit that like hit that like button
you never really know what you're gonna
watch yeah it said even I hope you have
the dark yet
but squirrel can do quite all types of
things apparents
I see you Champion Squirtle
actually technically I didn't Champion
Squirtle so you know pay attention
hey my attention span is very limited
yeah we got Lucius Augustus
we didn't beat the game addict we didn't
beat the games addict how you judging
which Mass Effect was best he actually
did he did beat the game
like that take that L yeah yeah he beat
them all and he beat them all like back
to back yeah it was like like a week I
beat all three of the games
you know I I will say one thing whoever
did that super track because I didn't
hear the name Lucius Lucius
you saw someone make a video trophy
shaming me
never talk that talk young wolf out here
yeah
he left the Squirtle loose
continue
what else we got something that's it
we're caught up let's just move on all
right let's move on let's move on so we
got to get the poll from last week the
results are in the people smoking with
the latest rubies regarding many
developers frustrated with the series as
Hardware requirements how do you feel
Xbox should address the issue the winner
of our three-way ILP poll with a
commanding 72 percent of the vote was
educate the devs multi-config support
has existed for years Xbox should assist
these devs and point to Studios who have
had success on the series s group coming
in at second king is killing me with 14
of the vote was the messy Lords how long
I don't care y'all need to speak to
these devs that's performing sorcery on
switch ports there we go and in last
place at 13 of the vote listen to the
dabs and drop series as support to focus
since you've missed out on this amazing
discussion last week your thoughts the
realm feels that um Edge that the the
devs these to be educated oh no that
wasn't even a Dev talk and that was an
artist
and me telling you since I did the
artwork on the cover I think we should
do that
this is what he meant by I have things
to say
two weeks he didn't get the memo don't
don't come for me unless I call for you
yeah listen go draw a little man and be
quiet
talk about little man and you drawing
stuff oh man listen listen I'm see I'm
not as nice as they are I'm dirty yeah
disclaimer time
you're not gonna come for the most
successful next-gen hardware and talk
about oh you know we having a problem
we're having a problem with nothing you
having a problem with drawing the angles
little man angles too hard for you oh
man little man has more 120 frames per
second games than uh your favorite
platform maybe you want to just develop
for your player your favorite platform
the one with the Disco without the
pregnant one or maybe is you don't know
how to do our DNA too oh maybe that's
the thing you're trying to shut it up
but I think the priority Clause is the
problem I think holding on to last gen
isn't that exactly what he wanted to say
last week
release uh on the PlayStation 4. I think
that's holding people back did you see
those Graphics
um so let's let's let's calm down with
the artwork talk and let's get down to
real devs because uh
Call of Duty was playing at 60 frames
per second on little man at 1440p oh
yeah it looks for them so don't sit down
and shut up because these dudes found
out exactly how to make little man work
rdna2 in the Box get all the A2 on your
other consoles before you start talking
those are the people holding us back to
come with they boarding passed how we
all going on in the flight and and these
people ain't got bored and passes we
could get in but [ __ ] so they got an
rgd too more than fast that's what we do
yeah if you ain't got audio in A2 please
shut up
and this is what King has been holding
on to last week I missed y'all too I
missed you too brother
Johnny was like Johnny
what's happening so anyway uh now that
we've got that out the way we gotta talk
about what's going on with these topics
man Lord song you are up man Game Pass
profitability and some price pricing
potential changes what's going on
so if Bill Spencer had a conversation
this past week the Wall Street Journal
held their uh Tech live conference and
Phil Spencer was interviewed during this
conference uh during which he uh he
announced every time his camera goes off
I'm just worried I'm worried what are
you about to do yeah oh yeah we know
kick turns his camera off things we're
about to Buck Up yeah
get ready to [ __ ] up continue but uh
yeah so Phil uh revealed that game pass
revenue is about 15 of of Microsoft's I
know Xbox's overall like content and
services Revenue right so he revealed
that and he kind of revealed that uh
that it is profitable for them and that
they've seen kind of a little bit of a
plateauing on the on the console side
because he you know he acknowledged that
hey on the console side
you're only gonna get so many people to
purchase right you may get some new
people coming in every single year
whatever younger people who maybe switch
players moving up to the next sort of
console whatever but you're gonna reach
some sort of a plateau point where we've
always talked about this when you talk
about Game Pass and where they want to
go and where they want to be the phone
is where it is the phone is where the
growth is going to be that's where they
want to reach all of these people and if
they can get them to
start liking core games then cool but
for them that's that's the big thing so
I'm going to see that he also did say
that there's a big increase
in Game Pass for PC that's where the
most growth is where they're starting to
you know a lot of the games that are
coming to game pass on the console side
are coming to PC at the same time right
which is what people wanted uh because
for a lot a long time you didn't really
see people seeing the value in the PC
side of game pass because it wasn't
parody with the uh the console releases
and then more and more that's less the
case so
you know he he admitted that he doesn't
think that the vast majority of their
revenue is going to come from
subscriptions which is again I think he
was a lot more candid during this
interview
expected right and and then once when
they broached the subject about you know
what's been happening with price
increases and inflation and stuff in the
industry he said you know we've been
able to hold price on our subscriptions
on our consoles on our services
um do I think we can do that forever no
not necessarily so there may be a point
we have to increase prices on some
things he didn't specify what
um but thinking about you know the
amount of content that they're trying to
push to to Game Pass right it it feels
like it would be game pass that would
see some sort of increase and that's in
a that's in an environment where we're
looking to see a family plan come into
play at some point right
so uh yeah it's interesting but again uh
he's very candid here and I I appreciate
that because again
when people ask these questions about
does Game Pass make money does does is
it you know how are they able to keep
putting all these games in this in this
you know subscription service and and
continue to function without losing
money hand over fist and you know he's
very candid about the things that make
money where they want to go and how
they're going to make money
what what is happening what is going on
that's a straight marker oh I don't know
what's going on right now where did I
know that's not the Halo 3 helmet so
that's definitely I don't know what's
going on but continue
that is it so what what do you guys I'm
gonna let you know how we profitable
too yo where'd you find the helmet that
fits you I'm gonna let you know
[Laughter]
gonna tell you how to get it done
Master Chief what do you think about
Bill Spencer's comments uh this past
week
let me tell you a lot of dudes was
asking us before
if we was making
him
obviously we making bread so Game Pass
is profitable now Big Show hell yeah oh
hell yeah that's that's exactly where I
rock out we profitable
multiplayer Chief well the multiplayer
is a disaster where is it well it's
profitable
the problem is is you're looking at
gameplay and stuff like that we're
looking at the profit
so the conversation is about to
multiplayer the conversation about
profitability and um I think we checked
that box okay okay because Big Chief
like there was a lot of things
because the big Chiefs so like there's a
lot of talking in the Twitter streets
you know about yo like you know Game
Pass is bleeding money they're invested
in the whole like you know did you feel
you had to get in front of these
statements and start talk to fail to
make sure that the public knew that yeah
it was probably I spoke to Phil earlier
and um
all he did was come back and said man
you good that's clear
that's cool so as far as I know is we're
profitable right I mean don't worry
about anything else you probably you
said we wasn't sustainable yeah that's
true we wasn't gonna make no bread we
were spending up too much money but I'm
guarding me
listen I'm about to go buy a new warthog
with a rocket attachment
I I love I love I love yo I purchased a
Humvee last week
[Applause]
like so I can't wait to get Call of Duty
episode Game Pass so we can really take
this to a no whole another level
so so big chief Big Chief you tell you
you might tell me you're getting
residuals though you're getting
residuals
how is that voice acting up hey how's
that working now
I see you trying to get me canceled
um but at the same time
big up to my peoples out there oh we we
were doing it way big we're profitable
I'll see y'all in 2023 where uh we will
continue with the escalants and and take
it to a whole nother level uh
profitability above uh marketability
respect respect I appreciate you big
chief for pulling up because um
especially the PC game pass numbers 159
I believe you know on PC she had a lot
of growth there move and all that stuff
so the Big Chief Bank came about he has
things to say he wanted to talk to the
people but uh let's get back to Johnny
because he's like what the hell's
happening so Johnny oh sorry I cursed
again
I will behave you're good you're good
Johnny that would make you curse I was
not ready for the listen oh that out of
nowhere I got a lot I got a lot more
Johnny this is going to be a wonderful
Sunday see I missed last week
gotta make up for it so yeah you know
that it all you know be perfect for Big
Chief and obviously Phil Spencer and
about gay past profitability you don't
want to talk about that and then also
your thoughts on the potential price
talk so both things the profitability of
the price like what's your thoughts on
by the way before we go on to that yes I
really appreciate that he actually said
the numbers so he said like 15 yes he
didn't have to say
any specific figures you know we would
have been happy if he just said
something vague but I do appreciate that
from him because at least the perception
I get is he's really straightforward and
he's you know he's out there with the
with the data it's not really hiding or
playing some kind of game with you and
then from a regulator standpoint people
have to understand that you know it's
not in anyone's interest to lie when you
got the SEC do you see your man you know
all these yeah you know about numbers
and stuff of that nature so and I get
people what like a lot of extra extra
specifics but yeah that is that's a good
point in reference to that but just I'm
sorry I interrupted your thoughts just
in general also about that and and the
price potentially increasing honestly I
think
the the price hike doesn't worry me too
much because it seems like the value is
also going up or the value proposition
of the service what I will say it's
until now I don't know about you guys
but I can still get the one dollar deal
very often
are you do you guys get that where you
go to you know to the page and it's like
hey here's three months for one dollar
or what's funny is I'm so locked in from
way back I got like two three years
stacked so I haven't got I haven't
really looked you've never seen the same
thing because I remember when they first
kind of announced it and they were just
kind of like getting people in you know
I mean so I've been one of those guys
really early adopters and was able to
get the two three years but people do
tell me that they still see them on
occasion like that so that's it yeah so
that that to me is like they're not
making money on it they're accepting
that as
not a loss but as a cost to doing their
business right which is getting people
under service
um and I think
the direction they're going towards as
you guys said is going platform agnostic
in a way yeah
you're playing on an Xbox chill you got
a Game Pass there are you playing on PC
games are there day one you playing on
phone you're a phone gamer no problem
here's a uh a phone version where you
can even use like a pen if you're on a
tablet many games now are getting that
which is awesome and with the cloud
stuff is just getting to a point where
yeah you can play it on any device yeah
I've seen Persona 5 like that it's crazy
people play full functionality with that
shot to judge Gordon and that yeah no
good points Johnny good points Lord
addict your thoughts Game Pass
profitability people get uh Phil getting
big chief saying it's um profitable and
then also you know a potential price
hike painting I want to get to that part
I mean I really um
I think I think as far as like
profitability like that I don't it's
like the Minecraft thing I don't
consider like people act like they're
not making profit because they've
invested so much but it's like Microsoft
knows that first off we're in the middle
of a recession and they're they're like
I'd rather invest season IPS but after
this is starting to die down and
everything goes back to some form of
normalcy like those IPS will be more
worth more money than it would have been
just sitting there devaluing uh second
off you know people be acting like the
Xbox division got to pay that back like
it's like no like that do you think that
when that Minecraft scenario is going on
where like they were sitting in that
little round table room like but Xbox
one can we expect this money back like
like they people look you got TV that is
running out of ideals we've seen that
you know they there's starting to
license games now license movies license
anything you can think of and now
Microsoft owns Doom that they can
license out like they own a lot of
different stuff that they can license
out to make more content like people act
like
when they bought these games it only was
relevant to games no you can do a lot
with all these IPS for instance when
they buy Activision you don't think that
they're gonna because right now I think
it's uh League of Legends starting to
make individual stories on Netflix right
Johnny
yeah that was I like that one you don't
think Microsoft's going to try to pursue
something similar to OverWatch
so we saw that with cdpr and Edge
Runners big hit
yeah OverWatch they got I mean Diablo
like they have a lot of stuff they can
dip in there man there is money to be
made that has nothing to do with game
nothing and you know they didn't go out
here and buy and spend billions of
dollars expecting it back in a couple
days well look I I do think that they're
bringing more in
then they're then they're sitting out
when it comes to like first party uh you
know versus what they get on Game Pass
because this this year has been a little
bit weak in my opinion on like the third
party day and date games uh so you know
they're not spending that kind of money
so you know they are making money but
it's just like when you consider the
Investments and stuff they definitely
ain't made that money back you know
Microsoft as a whole has made that money
back but I do think to some degree
they're like look like after this Call
of Duty thing you know we're going to
look for stuff that makes sense I think
they're going to start taking the
PlayStation approach like you know now
since we have Activision
we're we're gonna still pursue stuff but
unless it pops out with us that's We're
not gonna like go above and beyond for
stuff like that anymore yeah it's
interesting to track right especially
with the kind of year they had as far as
first party this year and they see you
know growth on any level and technically
the big AAA first party games haven't
hit yet right so I think the like to
your point you're saying like the
anticipation of the Activision deal
closing and some other you know deals
that they may have the eye on when
they're able to really Infuse it to the
service you know kind of could help them
more but it's interesting what solve
said too about the um that console space
limit and then going outside of that
with the PC and the mobile as far as
like the pricing and stuff going up did
did people really think we was going to
pay 10 15 forever big controversy right
now later that I don't care write it
down like you know record me screenshot
me I don't care like it's like sooner or
later these are going to go up now I do
think they're going to wait for the
Activision dough to go through and maybe
I think they'll wait for the First Call
of Duty to drop before they do that uh
in Game Pass you know regardless if
they're able to put next years if
regardless if they're next year able to
put Call of Duty in Game Pass I don't
know I do feel like they're gonna wait
for that first one to justify the
increase in bright because for the most
part people they'll still complain
because that's what consumers do you
know we complain but as long as the vast
majority can justify the price increase
usually it'll go one in one ear complain
for a couple days on Twitter then out
the other year and then everything just
goes back to normal like I don't like we
see with that sorry to cut you off like
we see with every other service Netflix
Disney not everybody prices go up with
time and they just try to match that
with the value proposition no that's a
good point it's a good book I do want to
ask you a question to push back no I
want to ask you because this is a good
point yeah subscription services do go
up every subscription service has gone
up there's no doubt but the question I
have for y'all
he said let's quote the quote was we've
held our price on console and we've
heard our price on games and
subscription so the question I have for
y'all what about this concerts aren't
going up and the reason I say consoles
aren't going up is because I'm pretty
sure like didn't Aaron Greenberg come
out straight out and say that consoles
weren't going out like someone came out
on this year I don't think we'll be able
to hold that forever I do think at some
point we'll have to raise some prices on
certain things but coming into this
holiday we thought it was really
important that we maintain the price we
have so it almost feels like this year
so you think you think consoles is
absolved from nowhere
I think he brought up consoles because
the person that was interviewing brought
a console yes okay I don't think that
like I think he brought up everything he
said like look Something's Gonna have to
go up I think next year star Phil
dropping's dropping seventy dollars
comes out and it's a massive success
they might raise the price of Game Pass
sooner so we think hold on hold on so
you think we get in the Starfield 70 and
the game prep okay I wouldn't be
surprised at both times at the same time
but it might be like six months to a
year apart it's just like look like
that's it's just what we live in and
people's like well don't support 70
games then I guess I'm not playing
nothing
like you like I understand well look I'm
not happy with games going up but on the
and there's a lot of different
perspectives that comes into it but I
guess my mindset's like yo we went two
generations without increasing games and
obviously in the states like did we
think that was going to keep happening
never really think corporations weren't
going to try to get more money out of us
but it's just like I don't like it but
at this point what am I gonna do you
ain't gonna play am I just not gonna
play Nothing am I just gonna sit here
and like no like I I play I spend with
them you gotta put your foot down and
play nothing I I put my foot down look
the only way I put my foot down is if
your game's trash
that's the only way I put my foot down
yeah
I I will say that you know I do have a
limit on price but it's not seventy
dollars
so if they start trying to get us for a
for a buck every time a game comes out
then I'll be like okay now you guys yo
we gave you an answer now you're running
a football field but like right now it's
just like look like I hate it I don't
think we should be charged the extra 10
but they got inspired passion ain't
nothing you could do about it just don't
play games I guess you know go go go
watch football here that's fun
it ain't happening man there's plenty of
stuff on Netflix to watch I mean you can
watch that you don't have to play games
yeah people keep thinking this is a
luxury like this is an essential in life
yeah it's a hobby interesting very
expensive hobby if your wallet don't
talk then sit down and shut up and you
know got another thing for you man if
you know that 70 dollars is getting too
much for you we got something called
Game Pass that you could probably pay 15
a month and get access to all these
stuff a bunch of games every month it's
like look and if that doesn't work for
you we got EA access you still got acts
you got access to somewhere you can
access to some games you won't get it
played and you know if that don't work
you know you got free to play you got
four now you can play for free you got
Apex Legends you can play for free
Advantage ain't no defense so you got
dragged for seventy dollar games and
they're gonna continue to get dragged
yeah
it's good now I'll get to it I'll get to
it okay I didn't drag them I said back
then that they they got you by they they
got you
there's only so much you can do without
without not playing like and people sit
there and say well don't play it I'm
sorry if if you're even remotely
interested in the game like do you think
that it let's say PlayStation starts
like you know we really gonna get them
and they and they put Final Fantasy
seven part two for 80 bucks next holiday
I'ma sit there and be like
I'm gonna need another ten dollars so
there's no limit
ten dollars and play the game
you know that
there is no
for games that I like but there are
limits for games that I'm curious about
that I'm not willing to spend the extra
money on for sure like if they would
have put Gotham nice for 20 bucks I
might have pulled up you know I might
have looked at it but but it's not it's
70. it's exactly so it's relative you're
going 70. you guys saw but that kick
it's kick the patience
no it's just
I think what they I think the 70 thing
on the Xbox side I think they're going
to try to hold off on that as much as
possible and I understand what addict is
saying with the with with Cod but I mean
the the buffer that they have is Game
Pass if you're gonna increase price you
can increase price on Game Pass and have
that supplement while still being able
to sell the games out of cart sixty
dollars and look like the good guy right
as long as possible I'm not saying
they're going to be able to do this
forever but hold out for as long as
possible because Game Pass is the buffer
with Game Pass you can justify it
because you can be like if they decide
not to put Cod into Game Pass which
again
at this point early on it's probably not
a decision of theirs they're going to
have to comply to a pre-existing
contract and not be able to do that for
a little bit but you know I to me that's
the way you do it because that's the way
you hide it the best right it is game
pass because I'm gonna be honest when
they went to 15 I was surprised they
didn't immediately jump to 20. right I
like nice round numbers for whatever
reason I was like 20 made cents back
then because people would be accustomed
to it already it's like oh 20 for all
this stuff right you know obviously back
then when when they upped it we still
didn't have your Forza Horizon fives you
didn't have your Halo there was there
wasn't a lot of stuff there we had like
Crackdown three and I could see people
not not wanting to justify that or
whatever got you well yeah I just I see
I see them working it that way I don't
see the only way I see a console
increase is if we get a new SKU of
console like we get the pro I mean we
get like we get it I would say big
generation refresh
refresh or redesign right or read some
sort of redesign
um that allows them to sell it cheaper
and then kind of keep the old one at the
same price you know what I mean
um again I don't know what their
thinking is on refreshes anymore if they
do another red gen refresh to extend the
console generation then yes there's your
price hype right there so solve I would
say before I give it back to you quick
question for someone gives you a dead
kick
um what comes first because you said
they would hold off so you think Game
Pass increase first before seventy
dollar increase yeah I think it's the
other way around all right all the way
around yeah I think it's the other way
around I think that they have
conditioned a lot of Xbox Gamers to not
necessarily care too much about the 70
price because the gay passes but I feel
like Game Pass going up would hurt their
bottom line more and I feel like they
they'll try to get money out of that
Avenue first and then
what if they got the Call of Duties the
star field I think everything's ready to
go and then the servers look beefy there
you go you like that if you look at the
seventy dollars there's like a 70 chance
of 70 dollar one happens I think there's
like a an 80 chance Game Pass goes up
eventually 80 90. and I think the
chances of consoles getting a price
increase is like 10 percent yeah I just
I just don't see that so King man
streets is talking he was like yo you
know we were concerned if Game Pass was
profitable feel Dominus Maximus really
expensive came outside you man you know
what I'm saying and said yo it's
profitable you know the silence a lot of
I guess critics did to talk about the
state of the industry and then also the
allusion to alluding to a price increase
you know what are your thoughts on both
of these things okay first so
um people got real quiet all those dudes
in the background that was talking about
oh game passes
there's no way they could be spending
that much money
I'm making no money they're bleeding out
they're bleeding out that Phil came in
with a bag of Band-Aids and say who
bleeding what the hell are you talking
about we good out here that's so big
chief
[ __ ] what he was doing money good out
here checks is cleared everybody feeling
good it's a good feeling on the side of
the room this is that's the thing
and price increases all right so that's
that's the big thing because we The
Narrative already been shut down about
profitability all right but now they're
saying they're saying you gotta show
more numbers they gotta show nothing he
told you to profitable yo do you go to
the Elon Musk and say uh can you afford
that
you can do that yeah you know you know
it's crazy
no one said Elon can you are you sure
are you 100 sure you can afford it
addict y'all implying that there's
agendas for why my subscribers nobody
asked Elon if he can afford the rockets
that he's shooting up again
nobody looked over at Elon wallet and
said um I don't think that's profitable
like here's the thing so people's
feelings are getting involved in your
sleep obviously Microsoft wants to make
money off of this Venture eventually I
don't think people really concept the
amount of money they can they can lose
on the this until they're willing to not
lose it anymore like they they're so
they are so extra with wanting to really
make up for a lot of lost time for what
their mistakes was back in the in the
past with the gaming now like
I don't they bought Activision like you
don't think a company that will go out
that they're trying they're trying to
you don't think a company that's willing
to spend 70 plus billion dollars on
something isn't understanding that this
is a long-term play you don't spend that
kind of money thinking that you're going
to dominate in a year yeah the narrative
that people have like they how they're
gonna make that money back like they
have to make it back in a week like like
Phil said himself like this is a long
term the whole point of the game passes
Game Pass is no no and solve we have to
put a two in this they bought active
well they're trying to buy Activision
they they're acquiring to buy Activision
with cash yeah
he's like hey Phil can we pull a few
Millions
let me let me check the cushions
it's like they went after Bethesda it's
like we need we need seven billion okay
get that out of the couch cushion we
don't need that oh it's like okay 70
Bill we needed for Activision all right
that's fine I'm gonna have to write you
a check on that one his his talks per
second
get your balls all right so now that we
realize you know that people have an
agenda against that goal post right the
goal post is pushed there 78 uh billion
I think was the number that they were
trying to achieve because they went down
I think was 13 off of uh the year on end
and this year this quarter that they
were just talking about the one quarter
I think it was like 28 uh for before the
quarter and this one quarter was like
2.8 billion something like that
that's profitability right that's
sustainability that's the ability to go
out and get a 501 I mean a 505 games and
go get their whole slate and put them in
game pass at a period here and there to
fill out a month we've seen games and we
talked about it earlier on games are
regularly dropped inside Game Pass and
addicts said to yourself that he's not
going to spend 70 on games that he want
to partake in but he would partake in
these games if it's in a service now
we're going to look at the competing
service that's in front of us that
charges you per single month uh 1899 per
month it's an inferior service that
doesn't have first party games inside
services that belong to oh God that
service belongs to the um
so the guys that's snitching and that
are fraud
ible
service that people don't find Value in
any way until first party is there
Microsoft shows you this first party
there now
this is where the goal post move comes
in they said well there's no games king
that's why there's no price hike this
year Goofy
all right so when they when when and
Trust and Believe when Star failed red
Forza and all these games hit Game Pass
day in date PC game pass uh Microsoft
Xbox game pass when they hit and you're
playing them in cloud and you're having
such a good time
don't be upset that game pass is 19.99.
to compete
with the nearest competing service which
is subpar that's charging you more
because right now it is at 15.99 and
it's giving you more than a subpar when
it's charging you more so they want that
money back all right now games prices
that you know
15 uh 65 I think would be
you do get a chance to say that we're
not 70.
with 65. I love the cat Okay and he
needed to hear this part basically he's
like you know I'm interested I'm not for
70 but he's in for the
65.65 okay 65. keeps you under that we
didn't reach that 75 price point and we
had 65. I think personally that works
there I also feel that game pass will go
up to that 20 threshold when they
release friends and family
now the thing is this either you can get
four more Buddies
and for five dollars more y'all can
partake or if you want to do this solo
if you want to be like Sovereign you
want to do it solo it's twenty dollars
for you
so you can either get down and lay down
right it's that's the choice and I think
that's exactly when it happens they're
going to give you good news and bad news
at the same time good news folks yeah 25
you and five friends and family all over
the world okay but if you're a loner and
you're cheap and you don't have any
friends
but that's when I think that happens now
as far as consoles go that's never going
to happen oh so you don't think the
console no I don't think Nintendo
doesn't and I damn sure know Microsoft
don't do it because those are the first
two people that came out when Sony
bumped their head and raked their face
against that rake and said oh we gonna
go up fifty dollars more tomorrow
today's price is not yesterday's price
this is where you make your stance at by
not raising that we can do it in other
areas that we don't have to do it in the
console space we don't have to penalize
the consumer now if it's a new product
that's something different okay if it's
a redesign of an existing product that's
something different but I don't think
redesigns will have a price hike I don't
think existing models will have a price
high now if it's a pro
then there will be a Price height
but but still we we should remember that
historically their margins on consoles
have been really small yeah like their
whole vision for the console stuff has
been that's not where we're really
making our money whereas Sony you know
that's a big part of their that's where
they're making money selling the
consoles right but for Microsoft it's
never been so unless they change their
Vision or Direction which doesn't seem
like it I wouldn't be worried about
price hikes for consoles or consoles no
doubt we got to break protocols so yeah
we got we got ACG in the building with a
hundred dollars Super Chat
let's talk about the best online search
which is for sure Nintendo
it's hard to argue that them ignoring
online totally isn't the proper plan
they don't need to worry about Hardware
either servers or the switch since it's
made from rocks and some rope anyway you
know
I really yeah I really enjoy a lot of
a lot of Nintendo games like Mario Party
Mario Kart and every time I play these
I'm like man I wish they would just stop
making the switch and become third party
and like allow other people to do the
online for them it's just like imagine
like Mario Party cross uh cross play on
everything right but no I gotta play
like uh like tendo party on Steam
instead like it's like all these generic
things I want to be
Nintendo party yeah I don't it's like
pumble party that's what it's called
pumble party it's a fun game but it's
not Mario Party look I'll jump in real
quick let's finish this balls off but um
yeah it was interesting I thought that
um you know for them to be as
transparent as they were you know right
now was interesting especially you went
to CMA and the Call of Duty you know
stuff uh running around so I I felt that
you know for him to kind of feel like
come out there and kind of talk about it
being profitable it's kind of a big
statement obviously you know there's
more specifics that we don't know but
look I don't have any reason not to take
someone's world that's under
investigation and under all these
entities watching I don't think it's in
his best interest to to be lying so I
know I saw that you know narrative kind
of going around but um you know what
slo-mo said what slo-mo said Slow Mo
feels like it's all front to make them
look even weaker to the C uh the CMA we
ain't gonna sugarcoat that you know
people are watching and that it you know
they're gonna you utilize certain things
today but how is them admitting that
their problems no he said
that it would always be 15 of the of the
Xbox income uh Game Pass and he's like
you would want that number to grow and
he feels like he's saying that just be
like look CMA I get it you over there
eyeballing all I'm saying there's always
going to be 15 signs
look I thought it was interesting what
he said about
um that they're basically the Castle
Circle right and about yeah how many
people you know they expect like they
didn't expect more to increase as far as
the console space and it is interesting
because a lot of people were under the
assumption that game pass is the end-all
be-all revenue stream for them right
like this is all in all and he's been
very consistent with saying that it's
one part and they recognize that at a
certain point you have as much as you
can have in the console space it kind of
plateaus out so that you see them
talking about the PC aspect it was like
159 growth you know which is tremendous
for them that means that PC game pass is
actually moving it's doing well you know
what I'm saying so the thing about yes I
would like
selfishly more specifics on the PC
number like what is it 159 from but
regardless to what it is growth in the
area that they really didn't exist prior
and you're seeing them push into them
spaces to go outside the bigger pieces
of the pie that to me is the end game
same thing we talked about with mobile
we've always talked about that and all
the things that they're trying to do so
yeah I mean I thought it was interesting
I thought it was funny that people got
emotional about this I was like why are
people so emotional that he said gay
fast is profitable I don't know what the
narratives were there forget people
killed me when they went straight to um
oh you know they they said that console
console uh subscriptions are uh that you
know they're not as high as the growth
as they normally are it's like look
there's a lot of PC people that's
finally giving the service a chance and
they probably haven't played a lot of
these games it's on PC game pass right
so they have a lot more value on there
but as Council people we've been we've
been there for a while the majority of
these we've played it's like the reason
that these numbers haven't increases
like we need they need games right so
it's like there's no sugar coating that
what's funny is like people sit there
and they'll say it 24 7. oh they got no
games but then when the results of the
no games this year comes out and Game
Pass numbers aren't as high as they
normally are they're like see this is
what I'm saying like but yeah we just
said that the remedy like yeah what the
thing is people have to understand like
with this agendas and this emotionality
involve people tend to pick and choose
the stats that fit the narrative you
know and I get it you know what I'm
saying it's your favorite team you're
riding for the set I get whatever my
whole thing is you know I want to see on
that aspect the long-term part we know
about you say the console space and we
know about okay they're going into the
PC space and these other spaces that
they want growth to go bigger than the
console space we got that far now second
part
the pro the price hike stuff thought
this was interesting you thought this
was interesting because this is now
negative tea leaves but right y'all
you know we we had console services and
games at this and we felt this year
right that we're not moving forward from
this right right we don't got nothing
this year right so we're going to stay
this year that right that's right so the
next year okay
that to me is interesting how it plays
that I think y'all all made good points
there you know with Services right you
know is it a situation where bam okay
now in a year that they potentially have
redfall Forza
um Diablo
um Starfield right you're gonna get this
word yeah is it is it now time that when
the first party's hit you know the hell
all that is that the time where it's
like okay seventy dollars you know
exactly what and and the interesting is
what soft said to me because look no
one's here is championing them for
seventy dollar games we're not sitting
at we're not saying that but the
interesting thing is do they still get
to play the hero role because you have
the buffer of Game Pass right so it's
like look yeah we raised it but look at
all these games we've given you this
year but if we subscribe to this service
that we got that we've been telling you
about you can have it's soften the blood
so I already know a bye bye in my mind
what the potential marketing could be
okay okay
no because the thing is and that's where
that's where it's funny when he said the
15 because the 15 night that's that's
gonna grow from there
like it's 50 down because let's be real
y'all have no first party major AAA game
releases
act like if y'all get Activision right
and Call of Duty and blizzard games and
all this huge backlog of Activision
Blizzard King that that they will see an
increase in subscribe and they've
already said that there are other things
holding up that they want to acquire
post deal right so the anticipation for
that to go up is going to be much higher
so I get the 15 right yeah the idea
the plateauing on the console side yeah
kind of true yeah like where you have
you know there are people that are
holding out people like they want game
pass for the premium game they want the
smaller games yes when they hit that
Cadence when they start hitting that
every quarter thing watch the
subscriptions go and that's the key
because the thing is they have been
surviving with growth with let's be
honest a double a triple A stuff outside
of the first but like you said now Jack
you get third party day in date games
and then those first party AAA games
they they know what they expect so we we
I know what you're doing so my thing now
is okay so we got that then you got the
game passing this is what king is I
think onto something big time right
because if the game pass then comes then
it's like all right we're raising the
price subscriptions can't be at this you
know at the same price forever right
but oh by the way his friends and family
and for you you two and three buddies
you know saying who you claim as
children will be part of yourself and
I'm very curious to see when that
launches because I think look no one's
here capping for increase let's be clear
I am not capping for no increase I I'm
gonna do what's best for me and I always
want the best deal for me I'm just
thinking of the mindset of what they are
going to try to do if this happens and
what the marketing speak will be and the
marketing speak would be oh by the way
yeah you know 20 ultimate but yo you and
four more buddies and now they got a
family yeah they're gonna show they're
gonna show the picture of them couches
that we showed y'all and they're gonna
be like you and your kids yeah
you're gonna see these type of pictures
[Laughter]
here you know to do that don't play
that's what he's doing extra you ain't
doing it exactly you're gonna see a
whole bunch of that and I think honestly
it's it's messed up as it sounds because
I know sodi got dragged I think they
gonna get away with this
they I think they could get away okay
the only thing I think they can't get
away with and I agree with all y'all is
if it's a console increase I don't know
but they do that
three years in they can't
you know a lot of people say oh there
are no games this year on Game Pass yeah
yeah I'm I I kind of take issue with
that because a lot of people have games
like Mass Effect legendary yeah you know
the complete thing went out there
obviously now we have plague tail uh you
know Doom 2016 came out there what's
going scoring uh I think Guardians of
the Galaxy
got some huge games that otherwise you
would have to pay almost full price
right exactly so like to me the value is
still there
um if you happen to not play those games
when they came out it's insane to be
able to play them right in the service
right
Johnny the the biggest thing is and when
when I say there's no games there's no
first party games like you know to be
launching and that's fair that's right
it's not Sony live right right we're
talking about grounded and stuff like
that those games are there but next year
next year we know that since they
adopted this model of day and date
inside Game Pass that's the time where
you capitalize on putting your
franchises out there that maybe some
dudes might not purchase on day one
because it's inside Game Pass right and
those other guys get a chance to
purchase when it's you know when they
don't have Game Pass that's when you
raise the price
it's gonna be interesting to see how the
marketing do but I I think there's ways
that they're gonna they're gonna still
look like the hero at the end so I got
this money but they're gonna be able to
pull itself for whatever buy this buy
this can also increase but um yeah
that's what I got these stupid Chats on
moving hold on a second Johnny let me
know how you're doing a little bit
um Johnny you want to stick around for
this one
I can go for about another half hour is
that cool yeah that's cool so we got you
for the stop no doubt we got we got 10
and oh with the five dollar Australian
Super Chat the Au is awake with all the
discussion around voice actor pay is cog
able to discuss what the bag is like for
his Cameo and Call of Duty
yeah they're killing me on Twitter right
now they are killing me with that Call
of Duty character yeah shout out to
Ainsley shout out to season gaming they
got me they got me it was funny you know
I'm running with it you know I think the
issue is that uh Call of Duty got you
yeah clearly I'm taking bags of
Activision yeah let's put the crest in
the chat for four is a legend and a
member for two years blood bronze thank
you sir then we have Forza Legend again
two dollars Super Chat Big Chief I'm
weak
he said Big Chief all right
then we got Jim dance Ryan with the two
dollars in the chat I want to watch but
football forgive me
let's go back and get the replay hit the
like button on the way in that's all
the way in just like push it in yeah
to a friend that could watch that don't
like football
then we have NC ghost of low road five
dollars okay I agree with King about the
friends and family plan gold gets rolled
into regular game pass as well as
ultimate and goes away as a solo service
yep I believe so we'll see we'll see it
maybe still make plenty of money off of
that throw those numbers up in there
those numbers
then we got CJ with the 10 euro Super
Chat from Ireland to the Lord's happy
Sunday happy Sunday to you soon
yeah CJ oh that's the homie salute you
don't even know when I'm coming back I'm
good up in Dead Island you already know
salute my God we're just rocking out the
what you call it the um Sinister and
vodka was walking out with the Pro 2
with um the Demi with a mixed reality so
you over there being BC with the pro too
and everybody got that everybody
everybody
you know it's a little Velvet Rope
section over there
doing the Tony Stark
stuffing up his cheeks
[Music]
no doubt no doubt let's get into it King
this is your topic I don't know if you
want me to set you up yes sir so um yeah
God of War Ragnarok man
um looks like they have released
um Sony Santa Monica released the
information regarding the graphic
settings so um looks like there's going
to include a 120 frames per second mode
they will have the option for 4K 30 120
and then there's um these are all pretty
much all the reported modes so favorite
resolution 4K 30 FPS lock favorite
performance 60 frames per second lot
then there's favor resolution High frame
rate 4K 40 frames per second lot and you
funny and then you already know it now I
know why we do it this time okay
favorite performance High frame rate
targeting 120 frames per second so King
clearly wanted to talk about the
settings in God of War Ragnarok so okay
the floor Insurance what's up man I
heard I heard so um shout out to the new
controller I got the new controller to
play God of War yo
so it's the new dual sense
yeah
it's the new Duke let's change the [ __ ]
I like this bro yeah you feel it you
feel a rumbling and and this this
controller talks with the light up is
the light up features so it's the new
God of War 40 frames per second since
you clowns
this is not a 60 frame spot there's that
there's a 60 frame but I guess with the
4K VR
it's an able vrr and HDMI one and have
an HDMI 2 to plug it into I mean
whatever lets me play is 60. I don't
care literally
this is the most convoluted thing and I
knew they was going to do this right
before lunch I knew they wasn't gonna
say anything I knew they was gonna wait
for the last second to say yeah 4K well
Dynamic 4K checkerboarded 4K because
they changed from checkerboard uh they
tell you Dynamic to make you think it's
especially happening did Microsoft start
with that language huh I don't have no
idea sir
just 40 frames per second that these
dudes is capping for this extra 10. I
don't even know how y'all see four but
so the 4K 60s which you got the fact
that they can't do 4K they can't do this
who's holding who back
is little man involved today
oh you implying only because they by
theyself and they can't do oh now I get
it okay I'll do it this is this is the
Triple A Banger this is the equipment
cream where's the 4K 60 at no
okay so this is payback okay because
this is okay truly play this is what is
really about so now
when y'all get the controller in the
mail
hahaha
that's how it starts up that's a startup
look
so
what I want y'all to say now
post on this one I don't want to go
that's what we doing okay
with every God of War uh yotenheim
Edition
oh I get it though just to clarify this
will not be in uh the collector's
edition we gave away okay so King so hey
so you're replying that PlayStation fans
were there was a little too much
enthusiasm for the what the artist about
the series s performance but now that
this is their first party exclusive game
and they can't hit 4K 60 so you take
issue with this okay I got it who's
holding back who
you are messy this is the best I didn't
know where you were going with this bro
this is super messy
[Applause]
I was wondering too I was like what is
it
about this before wow that's the only
kid could find out someone said did
Ireland get a God of War code no
PlayStation don't really mess with us
too much man you're welcome dude
this is probably a little bit corporate
for that yeah look outside the cake he
just literally called their uh made fun
of their control acting like it's
another controller so I could see why
they don't mess with us too much okay
because it is bad but anyway let's get
uh Lord Johnny here so obviously see the
settings the the announcement of all the
different modes for my God of War
Ragnarok and one what are your thoughts
on that and then two to King's Point you
know your issue do you have any issue
with the 4K 60 part not black okay so so
there are a few things there break it
down break it down yeah so let's break
it down one thing is that a 120 FPS
is preposterous for a game like this it
makes no sense because you don't see the
difference
okay so it's
when you take a game like this and you
bump it to 120 the things you're giving
up
for that
it's for no one will it be worth it okay
if this was like a competitive OverWatch
you know like okay sure go for it give
the option right but this is a single
player kind of slow moving right camera
right back there on the neck of the
character you don't need the 120. it's
100 a marketing thing for them to be
able to to say hey we have a game that
is careful
I'm training careful ground
I'm just trying to protect you for the
fair boys
I'm getting friendly with the sponsors
I'm on the couch okay
be careful
I love the
options yes
yes honestly it's a bit overwhelming at
this point because you have the favor
this with favor that it's you know oh
get this and that now you have 10
options and for the the Casual console
player who is used to two maybe they're
gonna be like okay but like what's good
what's the best you know what's the best
option so I think some people are going
to be overwhelmed by it personally I
like to see more options I do think that
4K 60
is not a required in my book however a
60 FPS mode is
for me nowadays is expected I expect a
60 FPS mode yeah how you achieve that
depends on the game some games
uh you can go 4K with it other games
to do that you would have to give up a
lot on the graphical Fidelity of
different things yeah and the overall
experience is just going to be better if
you have a dynamic resolution or a lower
resolution and you're bumping up other
things like particle effects and that
compounds The Experience more than the
raw resolution so I think a lot of
people get caught up on the number oh
it's not 4K however you have to
understand there's more to the picture
than the resolution it's what's what the
bits are packing right and in a way you
can sometimes pack more in less bits if
that makes sense no absolutely
a lot of junk [ __ ]
oh I forgot to ask you do you have two
kids what do you have any issue with the
4K 40 frames per second boat
Johnny
oh for me yeah so okay so people wonder
what the 40 is right what is that right
some TVs don't even have 40s tell them
Johnny
but so the thing with the 40 is it think
of it as an overhead so aiming for 40
means kind of like locked 30 in some way
right um so it's like it's kind of like
a stability you know like Rock Solid 100
Locked uh mode that's my understanding
of it that said I personally haven't
played anything in 40 FPS so it's kind
of a weird number it totally wrong solid
thing about 40 frames I'm not playing it
in that mode
oh God anyway uh Lord addict your
thoughts on the uh options the story
provided for God will Ragnarok and um
King's issue with 4K 40. yeah I'm
playing it at 60. that's my whole talk
yeah so you're going straight for the uh
the 60 frames per second one yeah so you
don't care about the resolution
yeah that game's gonna look just fine
I play I've played the last god of war
and it looked just fine so I don't think
it's going to be like a tremendous fall
it's called favorite performance 60
frames lock and then there's a favorite
performance High frame rate targeted 120
just the one Johnny oh okay okay so 127
720p
480p
but you said it's a 60 frames what what
is the resume they have not set the
resolution
yo this is payback for you I already
know what you're doing I mean the the
120 that's cute but it's just like I I
would it's nothing more I feel
comfortable at 60 without yeah losing
too much Fidelity or anything like that
let's be reasonable guys what are we
doing yeah
they promote
they promote 120 frames agility how much
you they promote 120 fames John how much
you want to bet this thing floats around
90 half the time so yeah yeah well
that's what they said it's not gonna
it's not gonna get that yeah 720p
got that side of here guys who's the
real potato
you know what though
that 40 frames is just a uh it's just a
mold they made so when this game gets on
the steam it's on the steam deck that's
a steam deck mode oh but yeah you know
you know what makes me laugh they're all
all this talk from attic they King like
they rocking 30 90s in their house yeah
like like they haven't been 30 FPS
forever talking about I'm not playing
that 40 like you haven't played at 30
for two thirds of your life and all of a
sudden now yeah and I'm just 60. and you
know the funny thing about it it's kind
of like not eating Fine Food your whole
life when you eat it why am I gonna go
back but this is the thing though but
you're eating Fine Food
at medium settings
it achieves all of this 4K goodness Yeah
medium settings
it could be it could be medium settings
but guess what that that high thing that
thing that you do I'm not playing a
PowerPoint it's just not happening it is
what it is
I understand that you just don't possess
the ability to play around with the
settings
I want Simplicity if I wanted to mess
around with settings and troubleshoot 24
7 I play PC dude
this is this is this is I I say where's
King going with this yeah
it's a great time they said to be one of
the best albums hilarious but I mean
look I threw it like I said I threw that
game on the other day the original one
and they they added that 60fps more I
can't look damn good look at it
um
better than I remember looking again but
I played it no no I think I played it on
a pro the first time it came out I I
don't remember but I mean again the
options we've had this discussion in
recent weeks about you know where 30 is
where 60 is right
um yeah everything needs a a 60 FPS mode
however you achieve it right and this is
the thing on consoles right and we laugh
we joke about it but the fact of the
matter is there's always concessions on
Console right you have to concede one
way or the other which is it goes to
this conversation about we were talking
about like okay
we as console Gamers we've been
acclimated now to the 60fps mode the
expectation is there yes the thing about
it is though we've been playing largely
a lot of cross-gen games yes very few
games have been this generation only I
think the scale moves again right now
that we're going to start getting games
that are more for this gen
we're gonna start seeing more I I
believe you know we're gonna pick the 30
the rise of the 30s coming back the
right because the thing everything
scales right everything is on a sliding
scale and if we move forward right for
the steam package everything
I'm telling you right now
we're at the point now where the
consoles are out two years right I know
we have all these bells and whistles
tricks VR you know whatever yeah exactly
FSR feedback
we are going to start getting games that
really take advantage of of the heart of
supposedly right so the thing about it
is this the parody thing no it's not a
parody thing no it's not a parody thing
it's about
that we are so bent on not getting any
more 30 FPS right and I think
from next year moving on
all these games that we start to get
that aren't going to be Crosstown
anymore
I thank you you're going to see one more
30 FPS no a man so I feel looking very
ambitious which is why it looks 16. no I
hope so and I I think they will hit that
on Console absolutely okay but next-gen
only Mr field yeah I know I know but it
wasn't started that way right I don't
think anything it probably was a
PlayStation version when somebody said
to hell with that old stuff right right
but who knows how much of the core the
base of that is still nobody won 40
frames
the 40 frames is interesting though
because the 40 frames just give you the
best of both worlds it is noticeably
smoother than 30 FPS 15 screens will
give you the best of both worlds give
you absolutely nothing's in our numbers
because it's an odd number it's not it's
not gonna trust me you haven't seen 40
FPS you're gonna look at it and be like
wait a minute this is much smoother than
the 30fps game the problem is they say
30 FPS but that doesn't mean locked
right so they they say oh here's this 30
FPS mode that is capped not locked right
which means it can go down right it can
go down and also in subtle ways so the
the delivery of the frames can also be
Irregular at times because we've seen
games
I'm loving Johnny right now because
Johnny the way Johnny talks and he's
explaining stuff he allows me to get my
comedy off no man I love it
you know I dig the enthusiasm the
enthusiasm
40 phrases
the 40 and it really is a big difference
even at a larger screen size right well
I can't wait to see this
well you have to do you have 2.1 if you
have HD yeah then you can see this and
that's and there you go that's what I'm
talking about oh will you be able to see
this do you happen to have this because
if you don't the 80 of people are gonna
see 30 frames per second
people who don't have the vrr yeah they
don't they don't have they know so even
if you have like a bottom of the barrel
from the barrel TV
your 30 is gonna look smoother because
the delivery of the 30 is going to be
completely regular unstable and we see
this in some games where they have
terrible start it's not stutter it feels
jittery yeah because the way in which
the frames are being delivered it's like
it's kind of like struggling right and
so that's why the overhead of the 40
helps even if your TV isn't displaying
40. yeah it's got that little overhead
that keeps it locked it's a bit of a
meme but it actually you know it does
help yeah visually because mark my words
bro mark my words as these games become
next gen only the consoles are going to
be three years out but they're gonna be
three years interesting because I
actually have the opposite intuition
Sovereign because I think
because when you think about it you know
we're using the same engines so it's not
like
as the the generation evolves
we're gonna move to something
fundamentally different so the type of
computation we're doing can go up people
can bump up particles and stuff but it
won't go up an order of magnitude where
we can't deal with that we have to keep
it at 30. and given that the 60 has
become kind of a staple and like people
expect that I think the hit you take
when you don't have a 60 as shown with
Gotham is a big one yeah no I they've
seen it so I I'm in terms of the way the
public perceives it I think they're
going to figure out Any Which Way
impossible to give you 60 FPS move yeah
I just think more and more they're going
to be they're going to give up more to
get there because I see what you mean
the Fidelity of the game it's pushing
the limits of like AI in terms of
density Fidelity obviously you know
these you know the PlayStation has 8K on
his box that machine ain't doing AK
nothing
like you I mean like sound yeah so it is
that thing where it's like will they
will there I'm My Hope Is that
everybody's like yo we got to reach a 60
FPS no matter what this game looks like
whatever you gotta do it doesn't matter
if we're going down to the yeah and then
I would say Gotham Knights is a bad
example because it's just not an
optimized game like it's it's just
optimized yeah I mean it had hiccups on
people running it on a 49th that's it
and I was like I'm like what is going on
here so it's that that's a bad example
but you know using games what happened I
said we're gonna use it though
you're gonna use it as a bad example
it's it's the only example in my case
Bessie but yeah I just I want to see
what happens when the next one comes out
that it's like oh it's 30 FPS base and
because of this reason because of that
reason you know it's a the world you can
go into every every building or
something like that um
I got too much to add on it
look Ragnarok you know the game looks
phenomenal um I Love Options [ __ ] gloves
options car gloves performance modes I'm
with addict I'm ignoring all that other
stuff whatever's the 60 I don't if the
resolution is with the resolution I just
want that fluid you know motion and um
yeah I'll take that but yeah I mean look
I like the fact that at least they're
offered it but I'm with Johnny I do
think the 120 mode in this particular
case is marketing speaking I think they
can't do it but you don't you're not
gonna get any to my opinion you know
obviously I didn't play the game so I
can't cap but in my opinion in that
style of game there's what are the true
benefits of 120 frames per second when
it's not a multiplayer twitch shooter
latency kind of a situation you know
what I mean unless they're gonna have
like this is like how fast can we make
it go with how ugly yeah so to me it's
like okay as a marketing Blitz it it
favorably makes for you stupid if they
look like the switch
The Witcher yeah
oh man look at the end of the vegetation
that was vegetation
it'll be interesting when they do the uh
comparison Craig mode
it will be interesting to see if the 120
vote how much is sacrifice for them to
achieve everything
they just running around with wire
frames yeah in that Gotham nights when I
turned on the variable uh frame rate
right no the rap not the variable frame
rate the rapper resolution where you
know it the resolution goes up and down
depending on what's going on bro
when you run around you can see the
jaggies
and then and only when they stand still
does everything come back together
oh man
shout out to right about shout out to
the team but yeah all we do is 60 funny
hilarious topics that's all I got really
on this topic but we got to respect
Johnny talking we did give him his half
but I know we have one more time so
Johnny I know you gotta run you know
what I'm saying brother an absolute
pleasure to have you in the round
brother you wouldn't care I'm sorry I
cursed but I I I I felt really welcomed
and uh just the enthusiasm the vibe from
from you guys just absolutely love it I
really appreciate
um you know talking about my background
and yes
I I don't know it
um making it feel like it's interesting
I'll I'll say it all right I really
appreciate it and uh yeah keep doing
what you're doing and hopefully we'll do
this again oh for sure oh for sure we'll
definitely bring you back brother
once we get someone in it's a lot easier
to get them back yeah right because that
sounds like a horror movie once again
the thing is I like that Jersey once you
get in you can't get out yeah doesn't
like to have people come in until they
have like the Royal Treatment like the
intro and stuff but once you once you
get that once like we don't do that
again
you cut there's like a cameo or
something for like a topic but uh
addict is telling you you don't get
treated special anymore
yeah once you come in we don't know
exactly you just go to the fridge
like the marbles you got the rest of it
right the high-end or you know or the
club right high-end Club yeah you come
through that first time you know I'm
saying we did the whole red carpet but
now you come through you know you got
that special yeah familiarity breeds
contempts
[Laughter]
brother I appreciate your story you've
been tremendous the the talent level yes
go get that album y'all yeah bro I'm
gonna put his um actual what you call a
page on there because it is really
really inspiring stuff check this out go
subscribe to the YouTube as well we put
together then put that in there go check
them out man super super talented dude
and um we definitely got to support yeah
again you know the gaming hike the
streaming everything that she's doing
and again salute brother we will have
you back and also from the best gaming
podcast you're in the best game yeah I
am and if people like uh twitch as well
I'm also there Johnny plays live that's
j-o-n-n-y without the H uh Johnny plays
live uh three times a week so yeah if
you wanna say hi to me would love that
no doubt thank you so much for having me
guys my brother appreciate it thank you
so much this is a lot of fun man you
definitely have you backing around again
brother all right awesome peace
so you want to get the super chats yes
sir hold on a second it's about to turn
up
uh let me see we got John Martin five
dollars
much love guys happy to see Johnny over
here too cheers for doubt we got the
rubber knob two dollars of attack it's
all about that 30 FPS filmic effect
y'all very filmic very filthy
then we got ko3 black truth ten dollars
gotta pull out the father of myself
you've been clowning the anime dudes my
whole life tried Persona 5 and now I'm
in love
it's different
then we got uh Phase 23 became why
twenty dollar Super Chat digital Foundry
is gonna make King look like a fool when
it comes to God of War Ragnarok well who
said that face who came from the King
face
it's gonna make him look like a fool
okay
fool if you ain't got that HDMI 2 you
want to do it just like me
gotcha
you looking like Anderson Silva right
now
he be about to smoke I give kids not a
rough knees look
leave face a shot at the face [ __ ] shot
the face
look up for me
I just I saw a video I don't maybe it
was doctor but I just saw a video on
Twitter saying that Anderson took a dive
like that last time once did a drop for
me
I think they doctored it because it
looked like he whipped in that I was
like I don't look right get the hell out
of here I think every time one of those
uh Paul brothers when they that's the
first thing it's it's doctor there ain't
no way he could possibly win it was a
good damn fight there's a good fight
yeah sir duck remember for 28 months
Lord bronze King is wild I'm dead thank
you brother I didn't like that he got
that controller he act like all that's
how PlayStation game
jumps jump ing it's the sounds
when they turn it up when they Boot It
Up
I don't like the sounds that Jake make
bro you gotta chill as soon as they put
that that God of War random Rock in and
they tried to do that I gotta ask is
where'd you find it if you don't have
babies anymore
thing is
I told you PlayStation 7 is to me
yeah you're part of the media team yeah
anyway
this is the 200 break apart put together
final topic that we've made it shout out
to attic
Persona 5 man what's going on the
streets are talking what's up
uh you know uh can you guys hear that
yeah no yeah a little bit of a oh you
heard something yeah these uh these
Hillbillies like Ram in the engine wow
yeah they got these trucks man these
trucks they're like when I be driving
down the road sometimes I'll be seeing
like trucks that's like lifted like like
four times the size of me with these big
big tires and stuff it's crazy it's
crazy that's their passionate though
it's their passion but uh it's a game
pass man we finally got Persona and you
know
Persona what is King doing oh no oh
he making up for last week this man
feels yeah I think to do things for last
week continue we finally got Persona and
you know a lot of people were under the
impression that
[Music]
this
is
[Laughter]
I can't I'm gonna go play VR I'm Gonna
Catch y'all later keep doing too much
today oh it's a game pass too
oh who is this phase four what was his
face oh cause it is
yeah that's because it looks like under
the hair yeah baby why do we have this
game pass Game Pass baby personify this
is how I feel this is what they see in
the dark right now
oh my God I don't know what's happening
this is Spooktacular
[Laughter]
so what does this mean like is this what
a certain fan base supposed to feel like
like what they're supposed to fear us
it was a fear when Game Pass is doing
right oh this is like we've got your
game moment we got your game we ain't
giving it back
jrpgs Rock vessels
King is the one king is the one that
demands the game sustain I'm the one
that goes and gets them oh very good
here we go
so we probably about some personas hot
now because
king's sitting there in the castle you
know I went over there I took Persona
I put it in the van yeah I was here I'm
the one should be wearing masks because
everybody here was hating like it wasn't
gonna happen
so y'all gonna celebrate off of my
prediction fine that's right got it got
it let's celebrate go ahead continue
continue adding to your topic sir so
after you know I snatched up Persona put
in the van and get in and send it over
there to the king you know keep
protecting can't leave they can't leave
you know I am looking for the
whereabouts of persona 6. yes yes so you
know if anyone got those that location
hit me up in the van
uh so you know people said yo Persona
isn't going to be protected No One's
Gonna Play it no it's it's not going to
be it's not going to be played
whatsoever and it's on multiple
occasions but on the top five to top
three of the most played games on Xbox
so it's like look like you know they're
gonna a lot of people are gonna go with
the mindset but addict this isn't
this isn't sales well you know what it
can lead to uh Lord King David sales it
can lead to sales on Persona sex
interesting
maybe maybe adding maybe if this is a a
test bed to see how we do over here
before they send Persona 6 over day and
days
I know man like it's just like one of
those things where it's like people
always like underestimating the the
people who actually play Xbox and
they'll be like oh because you know the
games don't sell well they act like no
one plays them over there let's start
with your head to it bro
look at you right now y'all do it too
much this is how we feel
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is whistle because people were like
yo they don't play jrpg so you get to
pop his bottles because he saw that
engagement because I'm looking at it
right now it's the second most played
game pass crazy that's it good thank God
it's crazy shout out to bed let me set
him up a little bit let me give let me
give uh Atticus flowers because this is
really really what so at the time
Persona 5 has reached the 10 top 10 most
popular games on Game Pass cloud and PC
the US console was 10 pc7 and he said
this is the best performance a jrpg has
ever had on Gamepad so it is a movement
We're Not Gonna minimize that in any in
any respect and um I'll jump in if you
don't mind yourself
I'll let y'all go okay you can jump in
thank you thank you thank you murderer
Persona and then the other Joker Persona
I don't know what's going on but um the
thing that is impressive
is that I told people the thing about
people keep saying why do people die you
know DFI we always give them like the
dominance Maximus and all that why do we
DFI and all this it's honestly out of
respect for
what he's doing that past generations
and past regimes have been unable to do
right and the thing is you say what you
want but Japan historically has always
been kind of a joke reason for them but
something they just never been able to
make traction and then also the whole
idea of big jrpgs big Japanese games
missing the platform that was that we
talked about it at that noise it's all
right the whole Atlas thing it felt like
they've just beat they go to the beat of
Their Own Drum even though Microsoft had
a good relationship with Sega so these
are the things that I I see especially
the marketing if you paid attention
they were marketing this like it was a
new release you know what I'm saying
almost coming today platform so they
understood the importance and I'm with
King on this part like I think there's
more to this because they are trying to
show we see it both ways you're seeing
Japanese developers say wait a minute
wow we put we gave you Cruiser like a
dragon over there right and we're seeing
the best engagement the best routing
since it was in game passes since it was
over there because I think there was a
hesitance there's a reluctance that
these are Regional titles that are not
going to do well in the west right and
then I think I would even shot a
PlayStation out
gave people a lot of confidence that you
can make a culturally impactful Japanese
style game and people go okay you know
what America is with this they want this
type of content and now with Xbox with
the jrpgs yo they're with it they want
this type of content and I think this
sets things up for the future so that if
there's a Persona 6 I'm not guaranteeing
game pass but the strong possibility
that yo this will be on the platform at
the same time as long so you have that
parody and this is how you make shrines
in the region it's been tremendous to
see I love the boots on the ground
approach they've really it's on the
ground
[Laughter]
all right that was good I like that but
it's like it really bodes well for them
in the future and it's not lip service
they are putting in the work in the
development and then we talked about
even with the Chinese games they're not
playing they didn't like what happened
with Genji and impact you're hearing the
stories yeah they're like weird and then
I told people that naraka blade.5 I was
shot they were able to get that game for
now I don't know if it was a time this
goes with the PlayStation version yet
but that style that game was huge on PC
that's right huge that isn't a
tremendous get this continuing we talk
about the woe long again huge get they
are serious people is it perfect no but
it is a tremendous improvement from
Passion intermission so yeah give them
that flower Persona 5 you're seeing
people who are not who've never played a
jrpg never played a Persona game playing
the game saying yo this is amazing it is
the last thing I'll say because I know a
lot of places to face like yo this is
Cap this game been out now it's hot now
and fair there's a lot of Truth to that
but you gotta also remember just like a
PlayStation fan loves the PlayStation
ecosystem and they want to play there
and they don't care about anywhere else
Xbox fans some of them feel that way too
they love their ecosystem so they just
want to play on the stuff that they're
comfortable with and that's all it is
and I think at the end of the day it's
benefiting the developer because now
they said yo we can make more money you
know same kind of thing so that's what
it is I give Atticus flowers give kick
his flowers that's what I want to say
that but soft you got anything else or
any of our other two personas
would be good no I mean real quick it's
like I said a cold day in hell and that
day is arrived
and I'm just glad like I think last week
was last year I was like yeah I better
play this yeah all this talk y'all
better play this and y'all playing it so
that's fantastic because again
the work can be done you know obviously
feeling the team and doing work to get
it get these games there and and this is
like the culmination right you've had
smaller stuff Soul hackers smaller games
Indie Games you know they're building up
there they sort of owned building up
smaller teams in Japan
but again like for Xbox to be so RPG
focused period and but not have that
foot in the door when it comes to the
jrpg this is huge this is huge and the
jrpg is really there was a time where
jrpg sort of plateaued a little bit and
they weren't as popular because people
were they they were tired of the
grindiness of them right and you you got
to the point where you started seeing
more action-based jrpgs they kind of
went away a little bit from the
turn-based stuff and it made it more
action-y they made the the grind less of
a big deal and all of a sudden they
started taking off again and then West
jumped on them all over again the way
that they had back in the SNS days and
you know when you have your Chrono
triggers and your ff6 and all your other
final fantasies on the on the SNES and
you know on the Genesis and stuff
Fantasy Star things of that nature so to
see this now happening again and then
straight up Persona 5 Royale is probably
one of the greatest jrpgs ever period
straight up this game it looks like it
pops up comic book yes stylish it is
just something special to you what I
like about it is just the known
willingness to you know when they
started the Persona franchise or
anything related that led to the Persona
franchise their mindset was like look
you know when people started demanding
to switch up the gameplay and final like
companies like Square Enix okay they're
like no we're building on this like we
we could do more to this turn-based
playing style than that we're doing like
we can do more and they they proved that
because they they went back to the
drawing board what else can we do and
then
you got Persona 5. and yeah it it to a
point it irritates me because it's like
I'm sitting here looking at Persona five
and I'm like man if if
Square Enix would have put the effort
into
building to building Final Fantasy and
not just caving oh we're losing some fan
base so let's do something different
right and but you know I feel like they
they knew that was happening but instead
of
going through there and just changing
stuff they're like let's just let's just
change it up let's make it better and I
have to give them that because a lot of
companies you see this going after that
casual bag they a lot of the times they
will cave cave that it's not a matter of
if they will okay because they see that
money they can make and they respect
that money hardcore and it's hard to not
to not chase that bad when they can feel
like they can get it easily absolutely
here's the thing I want to say add on to
that is that you know what's also
helping this is Phil's greatest thing as
far as game passes that was always
helping is that you're able to bring
game passing the amount of subscribers
that you have on it it's just install
base to present to make it more
attractive for them to come over right
with Persona is more impressive because
I felt like that approach worked well
with multiplayer and co-op games Persona
is not either bro I'm looking at it
right now this is Xbox game pass games
right so the people who are in the
service what are they playing number one
is Minecraft right expect it Minecraft
Persona is number two out of all Game
Pass subscribers Persona is number two
Next Step Minecraft that is impressive
you can't sugar I'm looking at I
refreshed it right now that is crazy to
me so it goes to show you there is a
desire for the genre if you promote it
right you get behind it right
you know you don't do late tweets you
know sorry they did referral dirty Xbox
yeah yeah if we had a good trailer I did
I just had agent Empire y'all got to
learn how to paste that a little better
but this this is you gotta you gotta you
gotta this is the only thing about this
is that I'm a little because now now
like they've been spoiled though right
because they're re-releasing the old
ones yes they aren't really doing too
much to them yes the old ones are a
whole different cup of tea it's not this
so it's like it's one of those things
like if they have built up the Persona 5
Royal it's hard going back to bro I mean
I think golden is great
but yeah what do you think why do you
think I think the reason they didn't do
that is if you start with those old
personas maybe maybe people aren't going
to have the mindset oh five is the
recent one they're gonna be like oh dude
how much difference could literally be
four to five and the amount of like
gameplay mechanics and Graphics between
those two is like significant they're
scared that they'll play those older
ones and not even try fine and then yeah
for those of you that don't know and
haven't played it yet all of these are
numbered but they're all separate games
I was like do I gotta go through he's
like
yeah they all separate you know it has
one they don't they don't go one from
the other yeah
well no it's you know it's Phil Dominus
Maximus Aurelia Spencer understanding
that this box is an RPG box and oh we're
doing that now okay yeah we we doing
that because uh I believe that it has
more RPGs than anyone and potential for
RPGs uh in the future
exclusively to the box is going to be
segment so
if you don't own a company you go out
there you try to get the best wears you
go and see in the market what is the
best uh RPGs and the jrpgs that's over
there that we don't have and for the for
the most part they went over there and
they got the whole Yakuza Series right
and it was a point in time when they
were all leaving they left for one week
one week and came right back so it
wasn't profitable for them
they wouldn't have came back they came
back and seen a Resurgence again because
those people that sword leaving was like
damn I didn't get a chance to play but
it came back and it was like oh let me
get in there now Persona 5 being uh top
two
that's a huge thing
in in this I keep refreshing it and I'm
like hey don't feel real I'm like yeah
it doesn't feel real right crazy but
it's a jrpg and it's showing that the
the appetite for consumption is RPGs on
this platform and if you think
that's a small feat
these companies see this engagement oh
yeah they know that there's a fan base
that is hungering for this type of game
they're not listening to Twitter in five
dudes I know that nobody played a game
with the no business right in front yeah
they're not listening to the five dudes
on Twitter they listening to what the
numbers actually saying they like oh we
can make money over here let's go so so
when people say oh no Microsoft is just
a multiplayer uh uh you know player box
like I'll just play Call of Duty just
play Madden it's just like a team sports
it's really an Americanized box that's
not true and and the metrics dictate
something totally different so here's to
uh the team Sarah bond in the squad
getting these games in Game Pass for you
to partake and then the engagement level
on purchasing is probably really high so
future purchases and future entries of
the genre should reach Game Pass and
that's something promising something
that we had no hope before but we have a
huge rare hope right now so when I said
the future was bright before on your
left
it's time to play yeah no I'm still
sticking by my oh you holding on am I
thinking I'm my thinking it just feels
like Sony locked that down a long time
ago look to your point if somebody has a
contractual exclusivity yeah go to 60 I
don't know nothing they can do to break
it so I mean yeah that's the case yeah
but I will say if there's no prior deal
in place because if I understanding you
know saying there's no leak yet what's
the what's the the video leaks yeah
so if there's not I do feel that this
puts I would I'll say I know you stand
on your Square I'll stand on my square
that Persona 6 will will make it because
if there's not a a contractual thing so
I'll just do that but yeah it's
interesting because they got a good
argument now to tell it's like yo bro
because if it's not now you could you
can negotiate better that's what I was
gonna say for sure 100 yeah if it's not
all right if it's not it better come
there oh yeah come on
it's like I said like
if there's no contractual agreement and
it is one of those scenarios where maybe
they'll consider okay you know we're
going to release this later because
you're going to pay us more money to put
it on Game Pass right it's just like
it's it's like I said a couple weeks ago
it's like you get to that point where
it's like you can continue to let these
companies like low-key extort you yeah
so it's a hard not to interrupt you I'm
sorry to your credit to your point let's
just say it solves scenario is correct
that PlayStation Persona 6 is exclusive
right for a Time exclusive whatever
right
it still embolden's Atlas because Atlas
is like okay we give you the exclusive
we get that bag from you and then with
the one year whatever it is here come
the Xbox we gonna get this game pass
back it has a second Zeitgeist yeah
there's a second there's a second wave
of of interest and it comes and it
bubbles up to the top again you know
especially if it's a PlayStation console
exclusive right and not and then when
the Xbox time comes around it's Xbox and
PC or whatever like it is now maybe even
a switch port or whatever whatever the
Nintendo console is at the time you know
um yeah see that that's the thing I
think they think about that as well too
because I like to see that Zeitgeist all
at once everybody just going crazy and
then let's say it's not in any
Subscription Service when it first
launches right then the second wave that
second Zeitgeist is when it comes to the
subscription services and people who
didn't want to dish out the 70 whatever
day one now have a chance to play it
right I I like that Zeitgeist as well
but I can see how these companies are
like yo we'll take the bag from one for
whatever reason marketing we don't have
to worry about marketing
we make it a year and then all of a
sudden now we have a second wave of
excitement because it's coming to these
other platforms I don't know I mean
again it just depends game to game
company to company but I I I'm just
tired of this having to wait because the
thing about it is you know how we are
man
you want at the moment when everybody's
talking about it and even though you you
know again I'm older I'll sit down and
play a game whenever it comes out it
doesn't matter
um but there is there is something to be
said about it being there day and day
everybody can have the conversation like
because some people an old game is an
old game even if they've never played it
there's plenty of people that's like
I've never played it but it's an old
game yeah
no is is a lot of Truth to that that
there's I think one thing about the Expo
Xbox ecosystem is they've also have this
mindset too where something new come out
and be like even if it's day to day
they'd be like well it's all gay pass
you know what I'm saying and they'd be
like oh well we gonna wait until you you
don't say the Xbox game has a lot to
play on Game Pass so that it gives out
the option to say you know what we could
wait so it doesn't affect us as much but
um yeah we gotta see it's gonna be I
will say this though the reason why I'm
still stand on my square is because
again
Atlas reports to Sega
Sega has the partnership with Microsoft
and to me
you gotta do what the boss said and I'm
still gonna hold on to that and I know
Atlas is the own little thing and I know
they outside but if the boy say we have
a partnership with Microsoft it'll be
interesting to see if that influence is
like get over there so we'll see those
games online yeah anyway that's all I
got y'all good yes sir right super
chatted up at least get out of here or
should I go to the pole first let me see
pillow yeah we don't got a few I don't
see nothing crazy
um one second
we can't
[Music]
Nova 30 M3 uh two dollar Super Chat
member for six months have a great day
gentlemen thanks for the laughs no doubt
you're welcome we got count stacula five
dollars
I like that
Us big Bank Boys by Persona five for
seventy dollars even if they sell it for
60.
you'll give them 70s they keep the
change to change the chase okay I see
you play it you play Persona on Game
Pass is a fraud and didn't really
experience it yeah
why why is a certain group bad that
people are inside like like it's by
you're not supposed to like it
bro that she's for the streets
like you can't get bad now she for the
streets I get it you love the first but
now that everybody else
get out of jail get out of your feelings
like them too that's that's just weird
energy to me like you're not supposed to
like it
people like a bag that's it developers
like bags that's how big number here
though I don't know when she was number
two are you I can't with you then we got
a Rel two dollars Persona 5 runs amazing
on xcloud and on your phone
look at that you can have her any way
you like it
that's why she number two over here
we love them
all right
loophole with the recent statements by
Phil Spencer of a potential price hike
looming in the near future which do you
think is the most likely to happen first
oh God the choices oh hey Xbox games
increased to seventy dollars
B Xbox consoles increase for inflation
you see Game Pass descriptions increase
in price on deep I don't care if all
three happen I'm out and I'm going to PC
shut up for the Lords in the realm shout
out to Johnny plays live held it down
tremendous issue the man is super Talent
gold support his channel we gotta we're
gonna put the links in the description
you know what I'm saying go support the
music the engineering the game in the
Stream and all that we're gonna put that
up in there and uh yeah man good show
let's get uh uh outros popping Lord
attic where can I find people find you
what you got going on sir
can follow me on Twitter at Lord addict
IOP appreciate Johnny come on it was a
fun time uh you know we've got some
stuff planned for you guys man we got
some stuff planned for you oh no doubts
cookies we're definitely cooking no
doubt Lord solved where can I find
people to find you what you guys know
you can find me going to work right now
that work thing that worked thing um but
yeah we got some some things in store
for you guys um hopefully I addict that
we have to we have an update on the the
pillows yes it doesn't tell me oh yeah
it's not update for me too yeah I was
trying to see if we hit the thing we'll
speak to it we'll speak Florida because
we can but either way either way next
weekend is going to be fun play NYC in
the building yes
it's gonna be fun um so yeah just just
tune in just tune in and all of them the
return of Lord King
Big Chief from somebody else
[Laughter]
oh man you can catch me on Twitter
having a great time with you guys that
come for me remember I got my dual sense
too
[Music]
hey you guys better watch out and I'll
definitely take you down
yeah I do not like that can chill at all
I love this control be trying to
represent the PlayStation with that
foolishness this is the best control
this is what I'll be playing God of War
on 40 per second 40 per second mode
or they say you're playing 40 frames at
40 per second mode
um
I'll be out here I'll make sure that I
turn off vrr that's the only way that I
can get 40 per second move
that does not represent the PlayStation
computer you need to stop sir they they
definitely remember
I do say this man it is so much fun uh
getting this out during the week because
uh like I'm gonna tell you right now
that I was trying to find a way to be
part of the conversation because you
guys hit it out the park and I'm sitting
in the car and I'm talking to you guys
oh you're talking to the podcast
and y'all was saying stuff I'm like see
and I'm pointing the wife I said see
that's why we all the same person in
different bodies because he said exactly
what I was saying she was like yeah
y'all are weird like that
um we're all connected and it's
therapeutic to have this release every
week to get these jokes out to have such
a good time and I'm looking at what kale
uh combat talk did last night those
numbers was crazy y'all guys are really
supporting kid and and I love it we had
a good time last night so again you can
find me on Twitter King David OTW if you
haven't subscribed if so what happened
to that dude that wasn't subscribed to
me could have won he didn't get the god
of war and listen I saved you from the
40 frames per second
next time follow me and then you could
partake too but Taz you got it
dope man
body can partake man so hopefully this
week
if y'all get these pillows y'all get a
chance to see something epic where my
man hits New York City when he puts on
that mask as he comes off that plane
yeah I'm gonna get arrested yes
was great yesterday you know solved
Super Chat
rubber knob five dollars in the chat it
doesn't matter you all know you can't
play 40 FPS on the TCS
[Music]
anyway look man everybody coming through
against with everybody supporting the
Velar hit that lick at the top and also
Advance GG 30 this weekend up into
Hollywood Halloween excuse me and then
um but again the pillows we hit that
y'all sort of venue so we trying to do
it real big trying to do a live show
that helps the mission so let's show you
my Crocs oh man I forgot about that
anyway
well make sure the camera peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]